CALL THE FIRST MEETING OF THE
THE AT TWENTY NINETEEN SESSION --
OF A IN THE TWENTY NINETEEN
SESSION OF THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER THREE THAT'S
A MOUTHFUL --
BUT IF SAID GOOD TO SEE A FULL
ROOM ONCE AGAIN AND WE HAVE A
LOT OF ISSUES THAT ARE --
INTERESTING AND TO A LOT OF
INFORMATION TO GO THROUGH OVER
THE COURSE OF THE SESSION.
I WANT TO FIRST --
WELCOME OUR TWO NEWEST MEMBERS
ELOISE ADDRESS AND THREE OF US
WE HAVE --
EXPANDED THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WHO ARE ON THE SUBCOMMITTEE AND
I'M SURE THAT'S GOING --
TO ONLY EXPAND THE IT'S ALWAYS
GOOD TO HAVE MORE PEOPLE LOOKING
OVER THE BUDGET GETTING CUT.
THE A CONSIDERABLE DOLLARS STATE
WE OVERSEE AND THE THE THE WAY
THOSE DOLLARS ARE BEING EXPANDED.
WE HAVE WE CAN'T TAKE ROLE YET
THE OKAY ACTUALLY WE WE CAN CALL
COR LET'S DO THAT NOW.
OF WHICH THE SPECTRAL.
BLOOM.
GARCIA.
MULLIN.
PATTERSON HERE.
YES.
RE BEST HERE.
OUR VOTE ONLY CALENDAR --
LOOKS LITTLE SCRAWNY TODAY
COMPANY HOMELY --
A THREE ITEM SOMETIMES OF THOSE
COUNTERS ARE EXTREMELY IF I
COULD GET A A A MOTION TO
APPROVE THE PHOTOS ONLY CALENDAR
WILL A MOVE THAT ONE FORWARD.
THANK YOU HELLO.
HI FONG.
GARCIA MULLIN PATTERSON HI.
RAY YES I REQUEST.
THANK YOU WILL MOVE ON TO THE
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY AND TO
MY UNDERSTANDING HE'S HERE --
MISTER CRAWFORD TO THE NEWLY
APPOINTED.
SECRETARY --
OF CAL EPA.
IS EXCUSE ME [inaudible]
REALLY.
WHERE YOU MOVE FASTER SO I KNOW?
I WAS GONNA SAY ALSO THAT
THERE'S A LOT OF ENERGY IN THIS
ROOM AND ABOUT 90% OF IT I THINK --
IS -- DUE TO
A MISTER CRAWFORD BEING HERE --
YOU ARE A MAN WITH A LOT OF
ENERGY --
SOAK UP PLEASE --
PROVIDE YOUR YOUR REMARKS IF
YOU'RE GOING TO DO AN OVERVIEW
OF THE NATURAL SOURCES AGENCY WE
WANT FLIP FLIP IT JUST I WILL
JEFF I WILL THINKS GERMAN WOMAN
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
GIVE YOU UP A VERY HIGH LEVEL
OVERVIEW.
OF THE NATURAL RESOURCES BUDGET
WHICH I'LL TALK ABOUT TODAY.
HI THE CHAIRMEN --
NOTED I'M THE NEWLY APPOINTED
SECRETARY OF THE NATURIST OR
SAYS AGENCY HI AND THIS IS MY
FIRST BUDGET PROCESS OF COURSE
IN THIS ROLE --
SO I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU ALL EASY --
AT THE AT THE TO THE HIGHEST
LEVEL FROM MY POINT OF VIEW WE
IN CALIFORNIA --
IN THE NATURAL RESOURCES OR STE
RESOURCES AGENCY --
FACE SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES ARE
CLIMATE CHANGE IS DRIVING
WORSENING DROUGHTS FLOODS AND
WILDFIRE --
RISING SEA LEVELS ARE IMPACTING
OUR COASTLINE AND THREATENING A
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE.
OUR GROUP OUR POPULATION GROWTH
AND ECONOMIC GROWTH A VERY GOOD
THING --
NONE THE LESS DEMAND A LOT OF
OUR NATURAL RESOURCES SO OUR
CHALLENGES ARE SIGNIFICANT THIS
YEAR AND IN COMING YEARS.
THE GOOD NEWS MY POINT OF VIEW
IS WE HAVE THE LEADERS IN THE
OPPORTUNITIES TO ADDRESS THOSE
CHALLENGES.
I CALIFORNIA VOTERS HAVE
PROVIDED IMPORTANT RESOURCES --
TO TAKE ON THESE CHALLENGES MOST
RECENTLY PROPOSITION SIXTY EIGHT
IN JUNE WHICH WILL TALK ABOUT
HERE TODAY.
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
HAVE LAD ON THESE IMPORTANT
ISSUES FOR EXAMPLE IN THE AREA
OF WILD FIRE --
SENATE BILL NINE A ONE PASSED
LAST YEAR WHICH PROVIDE THE
FRAMEWORK FOR A LOT OF WHAT
WE'RE IMPLEMENTING TO PROTECT
COMMUNITIES AGAINST WILDFIRE
THREATS.
AND THEN THE GOVERNOR ON THE
SAME TOPIC IN ITS FIRST DAY IN
OFFICE I ISSUE TO EXECUTIVE
ORDERS ARE FOCUSED ON REDUCING
WILDFIRE RISKS --
FOR INVULNERABLE COMMUNITIES ARE
ON VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES.
AND THE LAST OUT I'LL SAY I FEEL
REALLY FORTUNATE TO BE A
CALIFORNIAN AND LIVE IN A STATE
WHERE I BELIEVE ARE POPULOUS
UNDERSTANDS THE NEED TO PROTECT
PRESERVE.
UTILIZE OUR NATURAL RESOURCES WE
CAN CONTINUE TO GROW AT THE
STATE AND PROTECT ALL OF THE
NATURAL BEAUTY --
THAT MAKES CALIFORNIA SO SPECIAL.
SO WITH R
JUST HIGHLIGHT --
A HANDFUL OF MY PRIORITIES IN
OUR PRIORITIES AND I THINK WILL
MANIFEST IN THE BUDGET PROPOSED
BUDGET THAT YOU SEE BEFORE YOU
AND OF COURSE THESE ARE
ULTIMATELY DRIVEN BY THE
GOVERNOR'S LEADERSHIP AND VISION --
YOU'LL HEAR A LOT ABOUT THE
RESOURCES THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS
PROPOSED --
TO PROTECT OUR VOTE MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES FROM
WILDFIRE THREAT AND MANAGE
FORESTS.
I KNOW I CHAIRMAN BLOOM YOU'VE
BEEN UP TO PARADISE I SINCE THAT
TRAGIC OUR CAMPFIRE AS RECENTLY
AS LAST WEEK AND I IMAGINE OTHER
MEMBERS HAVE.
TO WE TAKE VERY SERIOUSLY THE
GROWING WILDFIRE THREATS IN
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE.
NOT ONLY AND THOSE FORESTED
AREAS BUT REALLY IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA COAST I EN INLAND.
YESTERDAY CAL FIRE ARE ISSUED --
PUBLICLY RELEASED THE REPORT --
TO THE GOVERNOR THAT THE
GOVERNOR I CALLED FOR IN THAT
EXECUTIVE ORDER UPON TAKING
OFFICE.
THAT IDENTIFIES RECOMMENDED
ACTIONS IMMEDIATE ACTIONS TO
PROTECT THE MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES.
AND IT STARTS TO IDENTIFY THOSE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE MOST
VULNERABLE NOT ONLY AS A RESULT
OF WILDFIRE RISKS BUT
TRANSPORTATION INGRESS AND
EGRESS TO THOSE COMMUNITIES AND
DEMOGRAPHIC FACTORS.
LIKE AGE AND MOBILITY AND CAR
OWNERSHIP --
AND SO --
YOU'LL SEE RESOURCE US FOCUSED
ON PROTECTING THOSE COMMUNITIES
AND EXPANDING OUR OUR FOREST
MANAGEMENT.
SECOND PRIORITY THAT YOU'LL SEE
IN THE BUDGET WE'RE PROPOSING IS --
RESOURCES TO MODERNIZE OUR BOTH
OUR WATER INFRASTRUCTURE AND
WATER MANAGEMENT.
BOTH TO ADAPT TO A MORE VARIABLE
CLIMATE AS I'VE NOTED AND MOVING
FORWARD TO ENSURE THAT THE THE
COMMUNITIES AGRICULTURE ANOTHER
ECONOMIES AND THE NATURAL
ENVIRONMENT.
IS ABLE TO THRIVE INTO THE INTO
THE NEXT CENTURY.
I IN SO THESE INVESTMENTS AND
WATER CRITICALLY IMPORTANT.
THIRD PRIORITY --
AT THE AGENCY AGAIN SHOWING UP
IN OUR BUDGET IS STRENGTHENING
THE CONNECTION BETWEEN
CALIFORNIANS IN THEIR NATURAL
PLACES --
WITH SPECIAL EMPHASIS ON
EXPANDING ACCESS OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS TO OUR PARKS HI IN
OUR OPEN SPACE.
MOST BROADLY ONE OF MY CENTRAL
PRIORITIES IS TO ORIENT ALL OF
OUR NATURIST WORSE AGENCIES ARE
PROGRAMS ARE POLICIES AND
INVESTMENTS.
AROUND BUILDING CLIMATE
RESILIENCE.
PROTECTING OUR COMMUNITY THE
NATURAL PLACES FROM THESE
CHANGES THAT WERE EXPERIENCING.
AND THEN IN ORDER TO DO THAT
REALLY ATTRACT AND RETAIN A
SKILLED WORKFORCE --
THAT WERE REALLY IMPLEMENT THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE GOVERNOR AND THEN.
PART OF MY JOB IS TO ENSURE THAT
OUR OUR DEPARTMENTS OUR BOARDS
AND COMMISSIONS HAVE THE
RESOURCES THAT THEY NEED TO DO
THIS WORK.
I WOULD JUST IDENTIFY OF A JUST
A FEW A COUPLE HIGHLIGHTS OF THE
BUDGET THAT YOU'RE DISCUSS TODAY --
AS I MENTIONED.
THE RESOURCES AND FORCED HEALTH
AND AND FIRE PROTECTION
CAPABILITIES --
WITH AN EMPHASIS ON ON ASSETS
AND PERSONNEL THAT CAN BE
DEPLOYED ALMOST IMMEDIATELY --
IMMEDIATELY TO PROTECT
COMMUNITIES FROM FIRE REST
BEFORE THE HEIGHT OF THIS COMING
FIRE SEASON THIS SUMMER --
AND SO OUR STAFF WILL GET INTO
THAT AND THOSE ARE RESOURCES ARE
REALLY INTENDED TO IMPLEMENT
THAT LEGISLATURE'S.
SENATE BILL NINE A ONE WHICH
AGAIN REALLY PROVIDES THE
FRAMEWORK FOR MUCH OF OUR FORCE
MANAGEMENT MOVING FORWARD.
HILL NOTE THAT ARE BUDGET INVEST
RESOURCES IN THE CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPS --
WHICH IS --
APART DEPARTMENT WITHIN OUR
AGENCY --
AND A SET OF LEADER WE ARE
REALLY PROUD TO HAVE ACTUALLY
VISITING OUR CAPITAL TODAY --
YOUNG PEOPLE DOING WORK ACROSS
THE STATE --
IN A KNOT ON A NUMBER OF FRONTS
BUT PARTICULARLY IN THIS CONTEXT
ARE PROTECTING THOSE VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES.
I IN OUR BUDGET INCLUDES --
UPWARDS OF A HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS OF GENERAL FUND
ACTS OUT OF THIRTY FOUR MILLION
SIXTY FOUR GENERAL FUND AND
THREE HUNDRED FORTY POSITIONS AT
THE CORE SO.
ARE VERY EXCITED --
TO INCLUDE THAT IN OUR BUDGET
REQUEST AND THEN WE HAVE
DIRECTOR NEMETH AND DIRECTOR
BONHAM FROM DEPARTMENT WATER
RESOURCES AND DEPARTMENT
OFFICIAL WILDLIFE HERE.
I RESPECTIVELY I TO SHARE MORE
ABOUT THE SPECIFICS OF THE
PROPOSED BUDGETS OF THOSE
DEPARTMENTS.
WHICH ARE OBVIOUSLY CRITICAL
TOWARD MEETING ALL OF OUR GOALS.
SO THANK YOU THANKS FOR THE
DILIGENCE YOU WILL BE PROVIDING --
TO OVERSEEING OUR PROPOSED
BUDGET AND I YOUR HELP ON
REFINING --
THE BUDGET TO MAKE IT AS AS
STRONG AND EFFECTIVE AS A CAN BE
MEETING OUR SHARED GOALS
PRECIADO.
YOU'RE WELCOME I THINK YOUR
COMMENTS AND I THINK THE
GOVERNOR --
THROUGH --
GOT YOUR DEPARTMENT HAVE SAID
SOME CHALLENGING BUT VERY
IMPORTANT PRIORITIES FOR SENATE
I THINK THE PRIOR JERRY
PRIORITIES ARE.
A VERY IMPORTANT --
THE DEVASTATION FROM WILDFIRES --
IS NOT LIMITED TO AS WE ALL KNOW
TO JUST ONE CORNER OF THE STATE --
IT IS EVERYWHERE --
ACT CAN YOU CAN --
I'M BY THE YOUNGEST OF FIVE FOUR
SIBLINGS AND THE WAS THE FIRE
HAPPENED AND OTHER TO THE
DISTRICT IN NEAR THE CITY WHERE
I LIVE.
OF THE THOMAS FIRE --
WENT THROUGH --
THE AREA WHERE MY BROTHER AND SO
LIVES IN AN AREABY FIRE
[inaudible]
THANK AND AT THIS POINT --
ONE OF MY BROTHERS HAS BEEN
FORTUNATE AND IT'S BECAUSE HE
LIVES IN A CONCENTRATED --
TO URBAN AREA BUT YOU KNOW NOT
THAT YOU CAN DRAW ANY
CONCLUSIONS FROM MY FAMILY BUT
IT STRUCK ME --
THAT IT'S SO --
KIND OF SYMBOLIC OF JUST HOW.
WIDESPREAD THE DAMAGE HAS BEEN --
HELLO --
WIDESPREAD THREAT IS AND WHY
IT'S SUCH A CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
ISSUE IN THE STATE FOR US --
TO JUMP EVEN HIGHER THAN WE HAVE
IN THE PAST.
A DOES ANYONE HAVE ANY COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS.
I THINK SHOULD HELP THANK YOU.
THE PROJECT YOUR HELP SIR.
IF THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
TODAY SECRETARY --
I HAVE A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS --
ON A COUPLE OF ISSUES AND ALSO --
STE SOME ITEMS THAT I WOULD LIKE
COM FOLLOW UP WITH YOUR STAFF AT
A LATER TIME BUT ALL START BY
ASKING QUESTIONS RELATIVE TO
PROP --
SIXTY EIGHT ARE YOU HAPPY WITH
THE ANSWER MAKING UP WITH THE
GUIDELINES FOR COMMUNITY ACCESS
GRANTS.
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTIONS OF
JUST GIVE YOU A LITTLE CONTEXT
TO WHERE I COME FROM ON ON TOP.
SIXTY EIGHT AB FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE IT GIVES THE AGENCY
AN IMPORTANT OPPORTUNITY TO
ACTUALLY EXPAND ACCESS OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS TO PARKS AND OPEN
SPACE. 5% UP 25% OF THE THE THE
BOND AS I UNDERSTAND IT --
CAN BE ALLOCATED TO IMPROVING
ACCESS. TO PARKS AND AND OTHER
NATURAL AREAS --
AS RECENTLY AS YESTERDAY OUR
STAFF WAS ACTUALLY TALKING ABOUT
HOW WE CAN ENCOURAGE THAT.
I THINK ONE OF THE ONE OF THEIR
TOPICS OR ISSUES WE HAVE TO
NAVIGATE --
WITH THIS IS TYPICALLY BOND
FUNDS ARE USED FOR ONE TIME ONE
TIME CAPITAL INVESTMENT.
AND MANY OF THE ACTIVITIES TO
EXPAND ACCESS --
COULD BE PERCEIVED AS I'M GOING --
SO FOR EXAMPLE --
ADMINISTERING --
A SUMMER CAMP IN A PARK FOR
DEVELOPING --
AN AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAM THAT
GETS GETS OUT TO PARKS TYPICALLY
THAT HASN'T BEEN A USE OF A
GENERALIZATION BOND FUNDING.
SO IT'S A QUESTION THAT WERE
WORKING TO NAVIGATE AROUND HOW
DO WE I REALLY FOLLOW THE THE
SPIRIT AND THE LETTER OF PROP.
SIXTY EIGHT AND ENABLE LOCAL
GROUPS AND LOCAL LEADERS TO
EXPAND ACCESS --
WHILE --
ESSENTIALLY STAYING IN THE IN
THE LEAGUE ASIAN BOND --
BUT IT'S A PRIORITY OF OURS IN
ONE I THINK WE NEED TO DELIVER
ON SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE OF IT
BECAUSE THE BOND WAS CLEAR ON
THAT.
YES I AGREE --
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO DISTRICTS
LIKE MINE WHERE THERE'S VERY FEW --
GREEN SPACES AND OUR COMMUNITIES
HAVE --
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO PARKS --
AND SO FOR ME THAT'S A PRIORITY --
THAT THESE COMMUNITY ACCESS
FUNDS.
ARE.
BEING USED YOU KNOW TO INCREASE
THAT -- BUT
I SHOULD MENTION WHICH WAS A WE
WILL FOLLOW UP WITH YOU YOU KNOW
ON ON THE APPROACH OF THE AGENCY
AND APART.
THANK YOU --
BUT DO ALL OF YOUR AGENCIES HAVE
FUNDING IN THE BUDGET.
OF FOUR COMMUNITY ACCESS.
LET ME MAKE SURE THAT I DON'T
ANSWERING CORRECTLY IN TURN --
TO BRIAN CASH AND AND LET ME
ALSO POINT OUT THAT WERE ON THAT --
PROP SIXTY EIGHT WE'RE GONNA
HAVE A PRESENTATION FROM THE
ALEJO COMING UP THE AS SOON AS
SIR -- THE
SECRETARY STEPS DOWN --
AND THEN --
WE WILL HAVE PRESENTATIONS --
AND AS OTHER ORDERED IN THE IN
THE AGENDA --
FROM EACH OF THE RELEVANT
DEPARTMENT --
TO HEADS AND AND THE SO WE'RE
WORKING WITH --
THE BRING CASH FROM THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY WE'RE WORKING
WITH OLIVER DEPARTMENTS AND WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE RIGHT
NOW TO ESTABLISH LIKE THE
SECRETARY WAS TALKING ABOUT HOW
THESE FUNDS ARE ACTUALLY GOING
TO BE.
INVESTED IN AND STAY WITHIN THE
PARAMETERS OF GEO BOND LAW --
THE IN WITHIN THE APPROPRIATIONS
THAT THE DEPARTMENTS HAVE
RECEIVED THEY HAVE RECEIVED
APPROPRIATIONS IN THE IN THE
LAST YEAR AND IN THIS YEAR THERE
SOME PROPOSALS FOR COMMUNITY
ACCESS WITHIN THEIR PROGRAM.
OKAY -- AND
I HAD SOME ISSUES RELATED --
TO MY DISTRICT THAT JUST --
FOR YOU KNOW FOLLOW UP --
I'D LIKE TO HEAR FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION ON ITS PLANNED
FUNDING FOR URBAN GREEN --
IN THE BUDGET --
AND THEN I'D APPRECIATE A STATUS
UPDATE ON EL DORADO PARK ON THE
PROCLAIM A WASH --
IT'S IN MY DISTRICT AND IT WAS
SUPPOSED TO HAVE BEEN BUILT BY
NOW.
AND IN REGARDS TO THE WATER BOND
FOR PARKS I'M CURIOUS TO KNOW --
YOU KNOW WHO HAS ACCESS TO THESE
FUNDS.
AND HOW ARE COMMUNITIES CAN GET
ACCESS TO THIS FUNDING.
THANK YOU SO WHAT I'LL SUGGEST
IS THAT OUR TEAM PROVIDE A
DETAILED --
FOLLOW UP FOR YOUR OFFICE THAT
WOULD BE GREAT.
THE BILL WAS THE NAME OF THE
PARK AGAIN --
ELDORA I'M A WATCH SO I AM --
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT.
THIRTY NINE WE WILL FOLLOW UP IN
A DETAIL WHEN ALMOST.
UP POINTS OKAY THANK YOU YEAH
[inaudible]
MS REYES.
JUST A QUICK FOLLOW UP ON THAT I
KNOW THAT SOME OF THE STATE
PARKS AND CONSERVANCY IS.
ARE DOING A GOOD JOB ON THE USE
COMMUNITY ACCESS PROGRAMS --
A STANDALONE GOT A STANDALONE
GRANT PROGRAMS BUT ARE WE
WORKING WITH ANY OF THE OTHER
DEPARTMENTS JUST AS MY COLLEAGUE
IS AS HAS ASKED. TO MAKE SURE
THAT THIS IS AVAILABLE TO OTHER
COMMUNITIES I KNOW THAT
INITIALLY THERE WAS A PUSH TO
HAVE 5% ACROSS THE BOARD AND
THEN THE LANGUAGE IS CHANGED TO
UP 25%.
MY OTHER QUESTION IS ARE YOU
HAVING PROBLEMS WITH THE FUNDING
AND MAKING SURE THAT THIS GETS
OUT TO THE COMMUNITY.
BECAUSE WE DO HAVE LOTS OF
COMMITTEES WHO NEED THAT
COMMUNITY ACCESS AND WE WANT TO
BE SURE THAT EVEN THOUGH IT'S
JUST UP 25%.
THAT ARE COMMUNITIES WHO DO HAVE
THE THE THE PROBLEMSWITH THE
ACCESS DO HAVE.
ACCESS ACCESS TO THESE COMMITTEE
AT ALL IT BRIAN ANSWER THE
SPECIFIC QUESTION ABOUT THE
STATE YOU KNOW MY ANTENNA
SECRETARY TO REALLY MAXIMIZE THE
RESOURCES --
THAT WE CAN WITHIN THE BOND TO
EXPAND ACCESS.
NUMB THE WAY I UNDERSTAND
PROPOSITION SIXTY EIGHT ABOUT
HOW IT WAS WRITTEN AND HOW IT
WAS DISCUSSED PUBLICLY --
REALLY WAS BUILDING THE
EXPECTATION OF EXPANDING ACCESS.
ACROSS CALIFORNIA PARTICULARLY
IN PARK PARKS POOR COMMUNITIES --
SO CALLED HER SUPPORT
COMMUNITIES --
SO.
AGAIN MY WHAT ONE OF MY
PRIORITIES IS TO ENSURE THE PROP
SIXTY EIGHT AND OTHER RESOURCES
ACTUALLY EXPAND THE ACCESS.
AND FOR THE THE INDIVIDUAL
PROGRAMS SOME PROGRAMS HAVE
STANDALONE PROGRAMS AND SOME
ACTUALLY MAKE IT AN ELIGIBLE
COMPONENT OF A PROJECTS THAT
THEY SUBMIT.
SO IF THEY HAVE A CAPITAL
PROJECT THEY CAN ACTUALLY HAVE
COMMUNITY ACCESS TO THAT --
SPECIFIC PROJECT OR OTHER
PROJECTS.
SO THEY ARE INCORPORATING IT
WITHIN THEIR THEIR PROGRAMS.
AND I WOULD JUST SAY BASED ON
THAT BOB THE SUBCOMMITTEE
MEMBERS INTERESTS --
PERHAPS WE COULD PROVIDE A MORE
HOLISTIC EXPLANATION OF OUR
APPROACH TO THE EXPANDING PUBLIC
ACCESS THROUGH THAT THROUGH THE
GRANT.
YEAH I THINK THAT BE GREAT
APPRECIATE THAT IT WAS CHAIR I
RECOGNIZE THAT THIS IS.
OUR FIRST MEETING --
HERE AND PERHAPS ARE GOING.
THE VERY FIRST ITEM THAT'S
LISTED -- IS
STATE PARKS AND TALKS ABOUT SICK
NEIGHBORHOOD PARKS. FOR OUR
COMMUNITY USE WHO ARE PARK.
FOR THIS IS A BIG DEAL AND WE
SHOWED BUDGET IN EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN GOING FROM TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY SEVEN MILLION.
DOWN TO TWO MILLION.
IS THAT SOMETHING IS GOING TO BE
ADDRESSED LATER IN TODAY'S
HEARING VERY SPECIFICALLY YES
AND YOU HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
ASK QUESTIONS THERE IS A WE DO
HAVE REGULAR RELEVANT FROM STATE
PARKS HERE THAT.
WOULD BE AVAILABLE AS OF RIGHT
CONCERNED [inaudible]
OKAY.
GREAT -- SO
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A
PRESENTATION NOW FROM THE LA --
ABOUT --
PROP SIXTY EIGHT AND APPRECIATE
YOUR TIME THANK YOU THANKS FOR
BEING HERE AND CONGRATULATIONS
AGAIN
.
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING RACHEL
EHLERS WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE.
SO SERGEANT HAS PASSED AROUND A
HANDOUT I'VE BEEN ASKED TO GIVE
JUST A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF
PROPOSITION SIXTY EIGHT AND AND
WHERE WE STAND WITH IT --
FOR SPECIFIC QUESTIONS I THINK
YOU DO HAVE AN AUDIENCE FULL OF
DEPARTMENT MEMBERS WHO HOPEFULLY
CAN.
ANSWER SOME OF THOSE DEEP DIVE
QUESTIONS THAT I MAY NOT BE ABLE
TO ANSWER --
IN THIS HANDOUT IS ONLINE FOR
THOSE WHO AREN'T IT'S A GOOD
OPPORTUNITY FOR ME TO MENTION
SOMETHING THE THIS BEING THE OF
BUDGET OVERSIGHT.
COMMITTEE --
FOR OVER TRANSPORTATION AND
NATURAL RESOURCES --
I THINK WE SHOULD ALL TRY TO BE
COGNIZANT ABOUT HOW MUCH PAPER --
GETS USED TAP IT'S ONLY ONE
LITTLE THING --
JUST IMPRINTING THE AGENDAS HERE
I'D LIKE TO OVERTIME DECREASE.
OUT WILL ALWAYS HAVE PAPER
COPIES AVAILABLE BUT RIGHT NOW
THE STACK IS ABOUT THAT HIGH FOR
TODAY'S AGENDA AND IF WE COULD
SLOWLY MOVE THAT NUMBER DOWN.
THE AGENDA IS ON THAT'S MY WAY
OF SAYING THAT THE AGENDA IS
AVAILABLE ONLINE.
AND TO THE EXTENT WE CAN ACCESS
THE THAT MORE TO HELP THE I CAN
ARE AN OUR WEBSITE AS WELL AND
SOMETIMES WE DON'T REMEMBER TO
SAY THAT AT THE BEGINNING OF OUR
PRESENTATION SO WE'LL TAKE THE
OPPORTUNITY OF LOCKS.
I'M SAID TURNING TO PAGE ONE
HERE PROPOSITION SIXTY EIGHT WAS
A BOND PLACED ON THE BALLOT BY
THE LEGISLATURE THROUGH SB FIVE
AND APPROVED BY VOTERS IN JUNE
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN FOR FOUR
POINT ONE BILLION DOLLARS.
IT DOES HAVE SEVERAL OVER
SEVENTY FIVE DISCRETE CATEGORIES
OF SPECIFIC WAYS THE FUNDING
NEEDS TO BE USED TYPICALLY IT'S
NOT FOR SPECIFIC PROJECTS THERE
ARE A FEW BUT MOSTLY IT'S
CATEGORIES OF TYPES OF
ACTIVITIES.
THAT ARE DIRECTED.
MOST OF THE FUNDING IS TO BE
ALLOCATED THROUGH --
COMPETITIVE GRANTS ALTHOUGH
THAT'S NOT TRUE FOR EVERY SINGLE
CATEGORY BUT BUT MOST OF THEM --
THERE ARE M. CLAUSES WITHIN THE
BONDS THAT STRIKES FUNDING AND
HAS A SPECIAL PROVISIONS TO HELP
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
SEVERELY DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE DEFINED
WITHIN THE BOND. FOR EXAMPLE
CERTAIN PROPORTION OF FUNDING AT
LEAST 15% FOR EACH CATEGORY
NEEDS TO BE USED FOR SEVERELY
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND IF
THERE ARE LOCAL MATCH
REQUIREMENTS FOR SOME OF THE
CATEGORIES THAT ARE TYPICALLY
WAVED FOR THESE TYPES OF
COMMUNITIES.
HI EVEN THOUGH JUST PASSED IN
LAST JUNE THERE WAS OVER A ONE
POINT THREE BILLION IN THIS
CURRENT YEAR BUDGET THAT THE
LEGISLATURE PROVIDED TO GET UP
AND RUNNING WITH THE BOND.
MOSTLY FOR EXISTING PROGRAM SO
THAT THEY WERE READY TO GET UP
AND AND GOING OR SOME SMALL
AMOUNT OF MONEY FOR STATE
AGENCIES TO TO GET READY. TO
MOVE FORWARD IN FUTURE YEARS --
AND THE GOVERNOR PROVIDES THAT
PROPOSES PROVIDING AN ADDITIONAL
ONE BILLION DOLLARS AND FIFTEEN
ADDITIONAL ADMINISTRATIVE
POSITIONS FOR THIS COMING YEAR
SO IF YOU TURN TO PAGE TWO OF
THE HAND OUT THIS PROVIDES YOU A
SUMMARY.
ARE THERE SOME CONSOLIDATION
HERE WE DIDN'T PUT ALL SEVENTY
FIVE CATEGORIES BUT GIVES YOU AN
IDEA OF THE VARIOUS CATEGORIES
OF THE BOND.
THE IMPLEMENTING DEPARTMENT HOW
MUCH THE BOND IN THE FINAL CALL
PROPOSED IN ABOUT FOR YOU THIS
YEAR -- YOU
CAN SEE.
THERE ARE SOME CATEGORIES THAT
HAVE VERY SMALL AMOUNTS OF MONEY
AND PROPOSED FOR THE COMING YEAR
AND THAT'S USUALLY BECAUSE THEY
GOT A BIG PLOP OF MANY IN THE
CURRENT YEAR --
EITHER THE FOOD RELATIVELY CLOSE
TO THE FULL AMOUNT OR A LARGE
AMOUNT AND THAT STILL IN PROCESS
OF BEING IMPLEMENTED.
I WILL DRAW YOUR ATTENTION TO A
FEW OF THE LARGE CATEGORIES IN
THAT FINAL CAT I'M.
CALLING HIM THAT.
ARE PROPOSED TO BE RELATIVELY
NEW THE THIRD WENT DOWN FOR
VOLUNTARY AGREEMENT SEVENTY
MILLION DOLLARS WHICH I THINK
YOU'VE GOT FOLKS HERE IN THE
AUDIENCE READY TO TALK TO YOU
ABOUT TODAY --
DOWN AT THE BOTTOM IN THE WATER
CATEGORY QUITE A BIT OF FUNDING
FOR FLOOD PROJECTS. FOR
SUSTAINABLE GROUND WATER
MANAGEMENT FOR THAT GROUND WATER
LAST YEAR THERE WAS FUNDING
PROVIDED FOR PLANNING BUT THIS
IS THE FIRST YEAR THERE'S A
LARGE AMOUNT FOR IMPLEMENTATION
GRANTS -- TO
START DOING PROJECTS ASSOCIATED
WITH THE SUSTAINABLE GROUND
WATER MANAGEMENT ACT --
AND AND YOU CAN SEE THE STORM
WATER BY A PROGRAM MULTI
BENEFITS STORM WATER MOST OF THE
FUNDING PROPOSED. FOR THIS
BUDGET YEAR SO ASSUMING THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS ARE ALL
ADOPTED THAT WOULD LEAVE ABOUT
HALF OF THE BOND FOR FUTURE
YEARS --
SOME SURE YOU'VE GOT SEVERAL
QUESTIONS ON THIS.
UP EITHER FOR ME OR FOR THE
DEPARTMENTS BUT ALL MOVE QUICKLY
HERE TO THE PAGE THREE OF OUR
OVER ARCHING COMMENTS SINCE THIS
IS JUST THE OVERVIEW --
IN OUR INITIAL REVIEW THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL SEEM
CONSISTENT WITH LEGISLATIVE AND
VOTER AT TEN WE DON'T SEE
ANYTHING KIND OF CRAZY.
GOING ON HERE IN THE PROPOSALS --
BUT WE DO WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT
ALL OF THESE PROPOSALS FOR THE
BUDGET YOU'RE WERE PRESENTED IN
ONE PACKAGE I'M BY THE GOVERNOR
ONE BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL ARE
BCP TECHNICAL BUDGET DOCUMENT
WITHOUT --
ANY DETAIL OVER THOSE AM
DISCREET PROGRAMS AND SO FOR
PROGRAMS THAT EITHER HAD
PROPOSALS LAST YEAR WITH A LOT
OF DETAIL ARE CONTINUING OF
EXISTING PROGRAMS THAT'S LESS OF
A CONCERN.
BUT THERE ARE SOME PROGRAMS IN
HERE THAT ARE BRAND VERY FIRST
TIME AND WE THINK THAT YOU YOU
AND YOUR STAFF NEED.
AT A FAIR AMOUNT OF DETAIL ABOUT
HOW ARE THOSE GOING TO BE
IMPLEMENTED.
IF THERE ARE NEW STAFF PROPOSED
WHAT ARE THOSE STAFF GOING INTO
HOW WILL THE FUNDING GO OUT SO
THAT LACK OF DETAIL HAS BEEN
CONCERNING THE ADMINISTRATION TO
THEIR CREDIT HAS BEEN VERY
RESPONSIVE TO ALL OF OUR
QUESTIONS ABOUT THOSE PROGRAMS --
BUT OF COURSE THAT INFORMATION
ISN'T PUBLIC WHEN WE HAVE BACK
AND FORTH TO THE ADMINISTRATION
SO WE'VE HAD A LOT OF
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT.
MOVING FORWARD IN THE FUTURE TO
HANDLE THESE THINGS AND IT IN A
DIFFERENT WAY BUT I THINK IT
DOES HIGHLIGHT THAT ESPECIALLY
FOR THOSE NEW PROGRAMS IS GONNA
BE REALLY IMPORTANT FOR
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT TO GET THE
INFORMATION THAT YOU NEED. TO
FEEL COMFORTABLE MOVING FORWARD
WITH THOSE --
THERE ARE SOME QUESTIONS I THINK
ON PAGE THIRTEEN OF YOUR DENT
ABOUT SOME OF THOSE NEW PROGRAMS
I THINK YOU'RE GONNA MOVE TO
NEXT THAT ARE BRAND NEW.
SO WE THINK THIS IS A REALLY
REASONABLE GREAT STARTING PLACE
FOR THE BUDGET YEAR BUT IT'S NOT
THE ONLY WAY TO PROCEED AND SO
WE WOULD RECOMMEND THAT YOU MOVE
FOURTH COLLECTING INFORMATION
BOTH FROM STAKEHOLDERS. TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAISES POINT IF
THERE ARE --
PARKS OUT THERE THAT ARE READY
TO APPLY FOR ADDITIONAL GRANTS
THEN MAYBE WE WANT TO PUT MORE
MONEY IN THE BUDGET THIS YEAR
FOR ADDITIONAL ROUNDS OF GRANTS
TO GO OUT --
I MY PRESUMPTION AND YOU CAN
HEAR FROM THE PARKS DEPARTMENT
IS THAT BECAUSE THERE WAS A
LARGE A PREPARATION LESTER THEY
MAY BE KIND OF WAITING AND
LETTING THAT PERCOLATE DOWN THIS
YEAR.
BEFORE PROPOSING ANOTHER
PREPARATION BUT MAYBE THERE'S
DEMAND NOW SO THOSE ARE THE
KINDS OF QUESTIONS --
THERE MAY ALSO BE KIND OF A
BACKLOG OF FUNDING FROM PREVIOUS
BONDS FOR SOME OF THESE
CATEGORIES THAT ARE.
KIND OF TAKING AWHILE TO GET OUT
THE DOOR AND MAYBE THEY DON'T
NEED PROP SIXTY EIGHT YET SO WE
THINK THOSE ARE THE TYPES OF
QUESTIONS THAT WE WOULD SUGGEST
YOU'D WANNA.
TALK WITH STAKEHOLDERS AND
IMPLEMENTING DEPARTMENTS TO FIND
OUT --
WHETHER THIS PACKAGE THERE YOU
MIGHT WANT TO MAKE SOME TWEAKS
AS YOU MOVE FORWARD.
AND WITH THAT HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS GREAT THANK YOU.
EXCUSE ME ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS.
SEEING NONE THANK YOU FOR THE
THE OVERVIEW.
OF UP --
PROP [inaudible] SIXTY EIGHT FOR
OKAY.
AND WE'RE NOW GOING TO HAVE --
PRESENTATION OF THE ACTUAL --
ITEM.
AND SO -- I
WILL GO BACK AND REPEAT ALL THE
THINGS THAT THE DAILY --
SAID I JUST WANT TO GET IN THERE
ANYTHING THAT --
YOU DIFFER WITH NELSON.
SO HONEST KEEPING TIME SHORT ON
WE DO WANT TO SAY WE'VE HEARD
THE CONCERNS OF THE LA --
AND WE ACTUALLY HAVE A MEETING
SET UP WITH STAFF FINANCE IN THE
ALLEY --
NEXT WEEK TO WORK ON WHAT WOULD
AMOUNT OF DETAIL TO BE PUTTING
IN THESE PROPOSALS IN THE FUTURE
SO WE WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE PUBLIC.
AND THE MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE HAVE WHAT THEY NEED
TO TO MAKE THE DECISIONS GREAT
THAT WE LOOK FOR TAKE TAKE THE
HEARING THE BACK ON THAT.
AND WE HAVE --
STAFF ASK QUESTIONS ON THREE
DIFFERENT --
PROGRAMS SO IF YOU WANT WE CAN
HAVE --
FOLKS COME UP AND START TALKING
ABOUT THOSE I THINK THE FIRST AS
VOLUNTARY SETTLEMENTS AND
THAT'LL BE --
DIRECTOR CHUCK BONHAM FROM FISH
AND WILDLIFE AND CARLA NEMETH.
FROM --
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES
[inaudible]
GREAT [inaudible]
WELCOME BACK.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS --
MY NAME IS CHUCK BONHAM.
AND THE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE.
PRETTY EXCITED TO BE HERE THIS
MORNING --
PARTICULAR.
PARTICULARLY BECAUSE I'M WITH MY
COLLEAGUES THE DIRECTOR OF WATER
RESOURCES.
COLOR NAME WITH I THOUGHT FIRST
WE INFORM YOU WHAT VOLUNTEER
AGREEMENTS ACTUALLY MEANS.
THAT MAY BE A QUESTION.
AND THEN KIND OF USE THE STAFF
PAGE THIRTEEN AGENDA QUESTIONS
TO GO.
THROUGH OUR KIND OF REPLY TO
SOME OF THOSE FOUNDATIONAL
ENQUIRIES.
SO WHAT.
DO WE MEAN WHEN WE SAY VOLUNTARY
AGREEMENTS.
THE FIRST THING I'D TELL YOU IS
IN MY EXPERIENCE WATER DEFINES
CALIFORNIA.
EITHER BECAUSE OF ITS SCARCITY
OR BECAUSE OF ITS ABUNDANCE.
WE'VE BEEN FIGHTING ABOUT THE
ALLOCATION OF WATER SINCE BEFORE
STATEHOOD.
AND IT'S VERY LIKELY WILL
CONTINUE ON TO THE FUTURE --
ARGUING ABOUT THIS VERY SCARCE
RESOURCE.
THE SECOND THING I'D TELL YOU IS.
WHEN YOU LOOK ACROSS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THERE ARE MANY
REGULATORY PROCEEDINGS?
AND DIFFERENT ENTITIES.
BETTER INVOLVED IN OUR DELEGATE
WATER MANAGEMENT DECISIONS.
A PRIME STATE AGENCY IS OUR
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD.
AT THE SAME TIME.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT OUR CENTRAL
VALLEY AND TEN ELEVEN OR TWELVE
MAJOR RIVER WATERSHEDS.
IN MANY PLACES THERE ARE ACTIVE
COLLABORATIVE EFFORTS TO
NEGOTIATE PACKAGES WHICH WORK
BOTH FOR WATER SUPPLY
RELIABILITY [inaudible]
HABITAT RESTORATION.
AN IMPROVED IN STREET CLOTHES
FOR THE ENVIRONMENT.
SO THE THIRD THING I'D SAY ABOUT
VOLUNTARY AGREEMENTS IS.
IT'S AN ONGOING EFFORT. TO BRING
WATER USERS CONSERVATION
COMMUNITIES LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TOGETHER.
AND DESIGN A COLLABORATIVE
PACKAGE.
OF HABITAT RESTORATION MEASURES.
IMPROVEMENTS IN INSTREAM FLOW.
AS WELL AS MEASURES TO ENSURE
WATER SUPPLY RELIABILITY.
AND PRESENT THOSE TO OUR STATE
WATER BOARD.
AS A COLLECTIVE COALITION EFFORT.
LITERALLY FROM ABOUT READING
ALMOST ON THE FRESNO ACROSS A
HALF A DOZEN MAJOR RIVERS.
AND THEN FACILITATE OUR STATE
WATER BOARD.
ENGAGING IN ANALYZING THE LEGAL
AND SCIENTIFIC SUFFICIENCY. FOR
THOSE PLANS TO IMPROVE OUR WATER
QUALITY ACROSS THE STATE.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE UP.
TO IT'S NOT EASY.
AND THAT'S THE SEGUE TO THE
SEVENTY MILLION DOLLARS YOU SEE
PROPOSE --
FROM PROP SIXTY EIGHT FOR THIS
PURPOSE.
DR NAME IF YOU WANNA TAKE US
THROUGH SOME OF THE QUESTIONS
ABOUT HOW THE FUNDS MAY BE SPENT
THOSE KINDS OF THINGS.
GOOD MORNING --
CHAIR BLOOM AND MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE MY NAME IS CARLA
NAME IF I'M THE DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES --
AND I'M I'M GLAD TO BE HERE ON
MAYBE OUR THIRD OR FOURTH A
STORM INTENT STORM COMING
THROUGH THE AREA THAT'S A GREAT
SIGN -- FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS --
THAT WAS A A TERRIFIC
INTRODUCTION BY A DIRECTOR
BONHAM INTO THE THE CONCEPT
BEHIND THE VOLUNTARY AGREEMENTS
ON THE WORK THAT WE'VE BEEN
DOING.
AND OF THE OUTCOMES WERE WERE
SEEKING THROUGH THIS PROCESS --
I WOULD ALSO ADD AND EMPHASIZE
THAT THE AGREEMENTS THEMSELVES
ARE ARE A WORK IN PROGRESS --
AND WE HAVE ADDITIONAL ANALYSIS
TO DO THAT WILL ENABLE US TO
DEFINE A COMPLETE PACKAGE TO
BRING BEFORE THE WATER BOARD.
IN TERMS OF TIMING OUR
EXPECTATION IS THAT --
WE WOULD BE ABLE TO PROVIDE THIS
INFORMATION TO THE WATER BOARD
AND WORK WITH THEM TO SUPPORT
THE ANALYSIS THAT THEY NEED TO
DO.
UNDER THEIR AUTHORITIES AND
COMPLETE A SECRET DOCUMENT BY
THE END OF THIS YEAR --
IN TERMS OF FUNDING THAT'S BEEN
PROPOSED --
ONE OF THE KEY FEATURES OF THE
VOLUNTARY AGREEMENTS AND HOW
THOSE DECISIONS WOULD BE MADE
ABOUT WHICH PROJECTS TO SUPPORT.
IS A A GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE A WE
HAVE A PROPOSED GOVERNANCE
STRUCTURE IN THE PROPOSED
VOLUNTARY AGREEMENTS THAT
INCLUDES --
THE PARTICIPATION OF ALL THE IN
STREAM OR INDIVIDUAL TRIBUTARY
COLLABORATIVE EFFORTS ALREADY
UNDER WAY AS WELL AS A GROUP OF
STAKEHOLDERS.
IT WOULD OBVIOUSLY INCLUDE
MEMBERS FROM MY DEPARTMENT OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE THE WATER BOARD BUT
EQUALLY AS IMPORTANT MEMBERS IN
THE AND WATER USER COMMUNITY.
AND THOSE PARTIES --
IN IMPLEMENTING THE VOLUNTARY
AGREEMENT WOULD GO THROUGH IT
AND ANNUAL PLANNING PROCESS --
TO DETERMINE AVAILABLE FUNDS --
BOTH FROM PUBLIC SOURCES AND
WATER USER SOURCES AND THE SWEET
OF PROJECTS THAT WOULD BE
IMPLEMENTED IN FURTHERANCE OF
THE OUTCOMES.
OF ASSOCIATED WITH THE VOLUNTARY
AGREEMENTS --
WE ARE LOOKING AT HAS THE AS
DIRECTOR BONTA MENTIONED.
WE HAVE --
FLOAT THE POTENTIAL FOR IMPROVED
FLOWS IN ALL THE INDIVIDUAL
TRIBUTARIES AND IN THE DELTA.
AS WELL AS A SUITE OF PHYSICAL
RESTORATION PROJECTS IN THOSE
TRIBUTARIES AND AND IN THE DELTA.
AND THERE ARE SOME OF THOSE
PROJECTS THAT --
WE CALL IN OUR WATER COMMUNITY
THE NO REGRETS PROJECTS PROJECTS
THAT --
FOLKS HAVE BEEN FOCUSING ON AND
FOR IDEA OF REASONS --
SOMETIMES MOMENTUM IS IS REALLY
WHAT IT TAKES TO TO PUSH PEOPLE
FORWARD --
BUT THOSE KINDS OF PROJECTS
EXIST AND STATE IDENTIFY
DOCUMENTS WE HAVE A SALMON
RECOVERY PLAN AND THE SMELL OF
RECOVERY PLAN.
THAT ARTICULATE A RESTORATION
PROJECTS THAT WE WE DEEM IN THE
BROADER COMMUNITY WITH
SCIENTIFIC SUPPORT THAT ARE
THINGS WE NEED TO BE DOING.
TO HELP THE SPECIES RECOVER SO
THOSE ARE THOSE ARE THE KINDS OF
PROJECTS THAT --
WOULD BE FUNDED WE DO HAVE
SPECIFIC LISTS --
THAT REALLY FRANKLY GO ON FOR
PAGES OF INDIVIDUAL PROJECTS IN
THE INDIVIDUAL WATERSHEDS BUT WE
WOULD BE RELYING HEAVILY ON THE
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE AND THE
STAKEHOLDERS --
MAKING THOSE DETERMINATIONS IN A
TRANSPARENT PROCESS ASSOCIATED
WITH THE VOLUNTARY AGREEMENTS.
SO WITHIN PROP --
SIXTY EIGHT THE VOTERS APPROVED
ALLOCATION OF TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THIS
ENDEAVOR. TO THE RESOURCES
AGENCY.
WHY THIS YEAR WAS THE REQUEST
NOT SEVENTY ONE MILLION INSTEAD
OF SIXTY NINE MILLION I THINK IN
OUR BEST PROFESSIONAL JUDGMENT
AS TO DEPARTMENTS RUNNING
RESTORATION PROGRAMS AROUND THE
STATE?
CONTEMPLATING THE SCALE OF THE
ENDEAVOR.
WE MADE A BEST PROFESSIONAL
JUDGMENT THAT SEVENTY MILLION
WOULD BE A USABLE ASSET. TO
BEGIN INVESTING IN THE HABITAT
RESTORATION.
HERE'S THE SCALE.
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT RIVERS
THAT INCLUDE THE SACRAMENTO
SYSTEM FROM READING DOWN.
THE AMERICAN RIVER.
THE FEATHER RIVER.
THE YUBA RIVER.
THE MCCOLLUM THE RIVER.
ALL OF THE LOWER SAN JOAQUIN
RIVER AS IT MOVES FROM FRESNO --
DOWN -- THE
TWELVE IN THE RIVER AND
POTENTIALLY OTHER TRIBUTARIES IN
THE SAN JOAQUIN SYSTEM.
SO IT'S A LARGE SCALE.
WE SEE RESTORATION THINK --
CONNECTING RIVERS TO THE FLOOD
PLAIN THINK ABOUT REMOVING
BARRIERS TO FISH PASSAGE THINK
ABOUT.
MANAGING BETTER NON NATIVE FISH
WHICH ARE HIGHLY IMPERILED
SALMON FISH.
PREDATION BY PREDATORS --
A WHOLE HOST OF THINGS HOW WOULD
THESE FUNDS BE MANAGED I THINK
WE WOULD FOLLOW.
THE RIGOR FOUND IN OUR EXISTING
GRANT PROGRAMS WE WOULD OFFER
OUR DEPARTMENTS AS ADVISORY TO
THE RESOURCES AGENCY WHEN IT'S
RECEIVING PROPOSALS FOR
INVESTMENT IN THOSE WATERSHED
SUBJECT TO THE AGREEMENTS
THEMSELVES.
WE WOULD USE OUR SCIENTIFIC
STAFF TO HELP JUDGE THE MERITS
WHICH IS SOMETHING WE'RE VERY
COMFORTABLE DOING.
AND WE WOULD FOLLOW THE WATER
CODE SECTIONS SEVEN NINE SEVEN
THREE TWO AND SEVEN NINE SEVEN
THREE SIX WHICH REALLY DEFINE
THE QUALIFYING ACTIVITIES.
THEY COULD AVAIL THEMSELVES OF
THIS PART OF FOR FUNDS --
I THINK THAT'S A BROAD BRUSH --
SURVEY OF WHAT WE INTEND TO DO.
AND PERHAPS WILL PAUSETHERE AND
SEE IF YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
THAT TAKE US INTO MORE DETAILS
[inaudible]
QUESTIONS --
I HAVE A QUESTION --
THAT YOU DON'T HAVE TO ANSWER
NOW.
HI YOU MIGHT WANT TO BRING BACK
INFORMATION THAT JUST A SHARE
WITH ME AND ANY OTHER INTERESTED
MEMBERS.
OF WHETHER THERE ARE ANY FUNDS
THAT ARE BEING CUT --
DEDICATED TO THE RESTORATION OF
MALIBU CREEK --
AND AND SO --
CHAIR MAPS ARE TO SPRING THAT ON
A TICKET TO SEE I THINK I CAN
ANSWER.
AND I'LL OWN ANY ERROR IN MY
ANSWER --
THE VOLUNTARY AGREEMENTS SCOPE.
DOESN'T RUN TO WATERS.
OUTSIDE OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY
BECAUSE IN A TECHNICAL SENSE THE
STATE WATER BOARD IS CURRENTLY
UPDATING ITS WATER QUALITY
CONTROL PLAN.
WHICH IS LIMITED AND PER VIEW TO
THOSE WATERS AND THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AND OF COURSE THE MALIBU
CREEK WATERSHED IS NOT HOWEVER.
I BELIEVE AGENCY OPERATES A
RIVER PARKWAY PROGRAM.
MY DEPARTMENT HAS IS YOU KNOW
ENTERTAIN FUNDING IN THAT WATER
SHOULD FOR QUITE SOME TIME SO
WHILE IT MAY NOT BE THIS SEVENTY
MILLION DOLLARS.
I'M REASONABLY CONFIDENT THAT
THE DIFFERENT PROGRAMS THE
DEPARTMENTS AND AGENCIES ARE
RUNNING THIS YEAR.
WOULD BE AVAILABLE FOR THAT
WATERSHED CAN SO THAT'S MY
MISTAKE I PROBABLY SHOULD HAVE
WAITED TO ASK THIS QUESTION --
AND OF VALUE WHEN YOU MAKE --
YOUR NEXT PRESENTATION OF MYSELF
LATER ON JUST WE CAN GIVE YOU A
LIST OF INVESTMENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN MADE AMOUNT OF CREEK
OVERTIME RIGHT THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER --
QUESTIONS.
RIGHT --
THEN THAT WILL MOVE ON TO OUR TO
HAVE A SIGMA.
OKAY CYCLIC RATE WE HAVE --
TERRON.
RAMSEY ME FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
AND MEMBERS IT'S A PLEASURE TO
BE HERE TODAY MY NAME IS TAREN
RAP IZZY ANY I'M THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF SPECIAL INITIATIVES
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES.
AND I'M THE EXECUTIVE LEAD FOR
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
SUSTAINABLE GROUND WATER
MANAGEMENT ACT.
B. S. SUBCOMMITTEE HAS PROVIDED
THE DEPARTMENT WITH A SERIES OF
QUESTIONS RELATED TO PROPOSITION
SIXTY EIGHT AND OUR REQUESTS
THERE IN --
WHAT I'D LIKE TO DO IS PROVIDE
JUST A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THIS IS
STABLE GROUND WATER MANAGEMENT
ACT IN THE DEPARTMENT'S ROLE
WITHIN THAT JUST? TO PROVIDE
CONTEXT FOR OUR REQUEST --
THIS IS STABLE GROUND WATER
MANAGEMENT ACT WHEN IT WAS
PASSED IS.
THE MOST SIGNIFICANT CHANGE IN
CALIFORNIA WATER LINE AND
CENTURY AND THE DEPARTMENT.
WITH SHARED ROLLS THROUGH THE
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD -- DO
TAKE ON IMPLEMENTING THIS ACT ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE.
THE CENTRAL TENET OF THIS IS
DANA GROUND WATER MANAGEMENT ACT
HOWEVER IS REALLY ABOUT KEEPING
AUTHORITY AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
WHEN SIGNAL WAS PASSED IT
PROVIDED THE DEPARTMENT WITH
DUAL ROLES A REGULATORY ROLE AND
AND ASSISTANCE ROLE AND --
PROPOSITION --
SIXTY EIGHT OUR REQUEST THEY'RE
IN IS TO SUPPORT BOTH OF THOSE.
WHEN UNDER UNDER SIGMA LOCAL
AGENCIES?
THAT ARE IN HIGH AND MEDIUM
PRIORITY BASINS ARE REQUIRED TO
FORM GROUND WATER SUSTAINABILITY
AGENCIES.
AND TO DEVELOP GROUNDWATER
SUSTAINABILITY PLANS.
THERE ARE TWENTY ONE CRITICALLY
OVER DRAFTED BASINS IN THE STATE
IDENTIFIED BY THE DEPARTMENT.
THAT HAVE A VERY AGGRESSIVE
JANUARY THIRTY FIRST TWO TWENTY
TWENTY DEADLINE FOR SUBMITTING
THOSE GROUND WATER
SUSTAINABILITY PLANS.
THE REMAINING HUNDRED AND FORTY
SIX SEVEN HUNDRED AND TWENTY
SEVEN HI IN MEDIUM PRIORITY
BASINS.
I HAVE A JANUARY THIRTY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY TWO DEADLINE.
SO THE LOCAL ASSISTANCE THAT WE
HAVE BEEN PROVIDING WILL
CONTINUE PASSED THE COD BASE
SINCE THE MIDDLE FOR THAT SO WE
COULD SUPPORT BEHIND MEDIUMS AS
THEY ARE DEVELOPING.
THEIR PLANS SO WEAK CONTINUE
BOTH AGAIN AT A JOINT.
ROLE OF OF REGULATORY EVALUATION
AND ONGOING ASSISTANCE SOMETHING
TO NOTE JUST WITH THE AGGRESSIVE
DEADLINES BACK IN JUNE OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WHICH WAS THE DEADLINE
FOR THE FORMATION OF GROUND
WATER SUSTAINABILITY AGENCIES.
LOCAL ENTITIES PULL TOGETHER AND
MET THAT DEADLINE WHICH WOULD
HAVE BEEN THE FIRST STATE
INTERVENTION DEADLINE WITHIN
THOSE LOCAL BASINS --
AND THE LOCAL ENTITIES FORM TO
THEIR GSA'S WITH THE COVERAGE OF
OVER 98% OF THE STATE'S
GROUNDWATER BASINS THAT'S A VERY
SIGNIFICANT SHOWING ON THE PART
OF LOCAL ENTITIES.
AND THERE'S A LEVEL OF SUPPORT
THAT THE DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN
PROVIDING UP FOR THOSE LOCAL
AGENCIES TO MEET THAT DEADLINE
AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THEM IN THAT CAPACITY AS
WELL.
SO THAT IS ONE OF THE SUCCESSES
IN INSIDE EXTENSIVE
IMPLEMENTATION PROCESS --
THE DEPARTMENT DID FORM THE
SUSTAINABLE GROUND WATER
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN TO SERVE THE DUAL ROLES
AS MENTIONED.
AND OUR REGULATORY
RESPONSIBILITIES DO INCLUDE
PRIORITIZING BASINS THAT MEANS
THOSE CATEGORIES SUCH AS HIGH
AND MEDIUM WHICH DETERMINE
WHETHER A BASIN HAS TO DEVELOP A
PLAN -- WE
ALSO HAVE DEVELOPED AND IS
RELATED TO GROUND WATER STANDING
BY WITH THE PLANNED DEVELOPMENT.
AND ALSO BASIN BOUNDARY
MODIFICATIONS WHICH IS A A
PRIMARY COMPONENT --
AND THEN OF COURSE OUR
ASSISTANCE --
ROLE IS COMPRISED OF PROVIDING
DATA INFORMATION TOOLS AND
FUNDING TO THOSE GSA'S TO HELP
THEM --
AGAIN ALL OF THIS IS TO HELP
THEM MEET THEIR VERY AGGRESSIVE
STATUTORY DEADLINES.
RELATED TO OUR REQUESTS AND THE
QUESTIONS THAT YOU HAVE ASKED OF
THE DEPARTMENT I WILL DO MY BEST
TO SYNTHESIZE ALL OF THEM INTO A
RESPONSE --
IF I DON'T TOUCH ON SOMETHING
SPECIFIC.
PLEASE CHIME IN AND AND LET ME
KNOW AND I'LL PROVIDE THAT
ANSWER -- IN
NINE IN MEETING OUR REQUIREMENTS
AT TO DATE THE DEPARTMENT HAS
DELIVERED ALL OF ITS REGULATORY
STATUTORY I'D DEADLINES --
AND DELIVERABLES --
BUT THOSE SAID DATES HAVE BEEN
STAGGERED --
WHICH HAS ALLOWED US TO WORK
WITHIN THE EXISTING STAFFING AND
WITH THOSE EXISTING STAFFING
RESOURCES THAT WE HAVE --
SO WE ARE ASKING FOR AN
ADDITIONAL.
STAFFING REQUEST OF NINE
POSITIONS --
THOSE NEW POSITIONS SPECIFICALLY
ADDRESS THE STAFF SHORTAGE --
THAT DOES OCCUR.
WHEN THE PROJECT IN THE NUMBER
OF POSITIONS SLATED FOR CHOIR
MAN SO OVER TIME WITH THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF SIGMA TO DATE?
WE HAVE BEEN IN WORKING WITH THE
GSA'S COME TO LEARN THAT WE CAN
EXPECT OVER FORTY FIVE
POTENTIALLY OVER FORTY FIVE GS
PEAS BY THEN --
JANUARY THIRTY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY DEADLINE.
AND THE DEPARTMENT IS GIVEN TWO
YEARS TO EVALUATE THOSE PLANS I
AND AT THE SAME TIME CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE ASSISTANCE AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL I IN THE MANY FORMS SUCH
AS GRANT FUNDING WHICH
PROPOSITION SIXTY REQUEST DOES
INCLUDE --
WE WILL ALSO ANTICIPATED WE'VE
BEEN LEARNING AND WORKING WITH
THE GSA'S THAT HIGH MEDIUM
BASINS CAN DELIVER TO THE
DEPARTMENT OVER A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY PLANS BY THEIR DEADLINE
THAT MEANS.
OVER -- TWO
HUNDRED PLANS THAT WE WILL BE
DEALING WITH THAT THE DEPARTMENT
ITSELF STAFF HAS TO REVIEW.
THIS IS NOT SOMETHING
UNFORTUNATELY THAT CAN BE --
AT HAND IT OVER TO CONSULTANTS
THIS IS THE TYPE OF WORK BECAUSE
IT'S A REGULATORY RESPONSIBILITY
THAT THE DEPARTMENT HAS TO TAKE
ON SO IN WORKING WITH THE LOCALS
WE ARE LEARNING MORE OF WHAT
THEIR NEEDS ARE.
AND THE TYPE OF HELP THAT THEY
NEED TO IN ORDER TO KEEP THAT
ASSISTANCE GOING --
WE DON'T WANT TO PULL AWAY FROM
THE ASSISTANCE FUNCTIONS WHILE
WE ALSO HAVE TO DELIVER IT TO
YOUR REVIEW TIME ON THESE MANY
PLANS THAT ARE COMING.
OUT SO WE ARE HOPING THROUGH
PROPOSITION SIXTY EIGHT FUNDING
THAT WE CAN HELP --
KEEP BOTH OF THESE REALLY
SIGNIFICANT DUAL ROLES ARE UP
AND RUNNING AND SUCCESSFUL TO
HELP THESE LOCAL AGENCIES KEEP
CONTROL OF THEIR BASINS.
SO -- ALONG
WITH THAT THE WE DO NEED TO
ADDRESS.
R. G. S. P.'S WITHIN THE TWO
YEAR SUBMIT ALL WE WILL ALSO BE
RECEIVING ALTERNATIVE --
SKEWS ME I ANNUAL REPORTS FOR
THOSE PLANS THAT COME IN WE ALSO --
WILL BE RECEIVING FIVE YEAR
UPDATES TO THOSE GROUND WATER
SUSTAINABILITY PLANS --
WE WILL ALSO BE RECEIVING AND
HAVING TO COLLECT IN MANAGE
REPORTING FROM THOSE BASINS THAT
HAVE EDUCATIONS WITHIN THEM.
SO THESE ARE ALL THINGS THAT ARE
REQUIRING.
LEVEL OF TRAINING FROM STAFF
THAT WE NEED TO RAMP UP NOW
BEFORE THOSE DEADLINES BEGAN
COMING --
WITHOUT THE NINE NEW POSITIONS --
AGAIN THESE SUPPORTIVE
ACTIVITIES WILL BE GREATLY
IMPACTED --
AND SO WE DEFINITELY APPRECIATE --
YOUR ATTENTION TO THAT REQUEST.
TO MOVE ON TO A COUPLE OF THE
OTHER QUESTIONS --
THERE WAS A QUESTION RELATED TO
THE SIX NEW POSITIONS IN Y.
STOCK WORK LOAD HAS INCREASED.
AND I BELIEVE I DID COVER THIS
BUT I JUST WANT TO INSURE THAT
WE ARE LOOKING AT A NUMBER THAT
HAS ESSENTIALLY DOUBLED FOR THE
TWENTY TWENTY DEADLINE FOR
CRITICALLY OVER DRAFTED BASINS.
GSA'S HAVE THE ABILITY TO
DELIVER THEIR OWN PLAN WE HAVE
TWO INTERN SIXTY SEVEN GSA'S IN
THE STATE.
AND THEY ARE ALLOWED TO DELIVER
THEIR OWN GROUND WATER BUT
WITHIN THE BASIN EACH BASIN IS
APPROACHING HOWEVER HOW THEY
WANT TO DELIVER THEIR GROUND
WATER SUSTAINABILITY PLANS.
SO MULTIPLE GSA'S CAN DELIVER
MULTIPLE TIAS PEAS ARE PLANS FOR
THAT BASIN OR THERE COULD BE ONE
BASIN WITH ONE PLAN.
SO AS THAT'S BEING DEVELOPED AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL THROUGH THAT
GOVERNMENT STRUCTURE WE'RE
GETTING MORE OF THE INFORMATION
AS TO HOW MANY WE CAN BE
EXPECTING TO THAN THAT GOES BACK
TO HOW WE'RE LEARNING THERE'S
RIGHT NOW KIND OF A DOUBLING.
OF THE PLANS THAT WERE
ANTICIPATED --
TO TOUCH ON THE EXISTING
GROUNDWATER --
MANAGEMENT PLANNING GRANTS THAT
WERE FUNDED IN THE CURE CURRENT
IN PRIOR YEARS --
THE FIRST ROUND --
WE WERE AWARDED --
WE AWARDED SIX POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS TO TWENTY ONE
COUNTIES WITH STRESSED BASINS IN
MAY OF TWENTY SIXTEEN AND EACH
OF THOSE TWENTY ONE GRANT
RECIPIENTS HAVE EITHER COMPLETED
OR WILL COMPLETE.
THEIR WORK THIS SPRING THE
SECOND ROUND WAS --
ON A WARNING OF EIGHTY FIVE
POINT EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS THIS
IS THROUGH PROPOSITION WHEN I'M
SORRY TO CLARIFY THAT --
PROPOSITION ONE WE RECEIVED A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO
SUPPORT THESE PLANNING GRANTS --
MILLION WAS SEVENTY EIGHT
APPLICANTS.
AND AS OVER SIXTEEN MILLION WAS
PROVIDED TO DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND SEVERELY
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES --
THE DEMAND FOR IMPLEMENTATION
GRANTS -- IS
GOING TO BE VERY HIGH.
HELPING THE LOCALS CREATE THE
PLANNING --
AND THE TOOLS FOR PLANNING TO
DELIVER THEIR GROUND WATER
SUSTAINABILITY PLANS IS VERY
VERY IMPORTANT BUT THE MINUTE
THOSE PLANS ARE SUBMITTED.
THE GSA'S ARE REQUIRED TO
IMMEDIATELY IMPLEMENT.
THE PLANS EVEN WHILE WE AS THE
DEPARTMENT ARE EVALUATING.
THE ADEQUACY OF THOSE PLANS SO
AT CIGNA IS REALLY --
TURNING THE TIDE TO ENSURE THAT
LOCALS ARE ARE INCREASING THE
MANAGEMENT AND THE
SUSTAINABILITY OF THEIR BASE AND
SO IMMEDIATE --
IMPLEMENTATION OF THAT IS
IMPORTANT AND THAT'S WHAT PROP
SIXTY EIGHT IS --
OFFERING ALLOWING US FOR
PURSUING A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS FOR IMPLEMENTATION.
GRANTS THAT WE WANT --
TO SUPPORT LOCALS WITH YEARS --
TO CONTINUE WITH THE PLANNING
GRANTS --
BECAUSE MANY OF OUR PLANNING
GRANTS OF GOING OUT TO
CRITICALLY OVER DRAFTED BASINS
WE ARE TRYING TO PRIORITIZE
THOSE AREAS.
BUT THERE ARE STILL HIçN
MEDIUM PRIORITY BASINS WITH
THEIR TWENTY TWENTY TWO DEADLINE
THAT THAT DO NEED.
A THAT SUPPORT AS WELL SO
PROPOSITION ONE PROVIDED A
CERTAIN AMOUNT WE APPRECIATE
WITH THE PASSAGE OF PROP SIXTY
EIGHT THAT WE CAN CONTINUE THAT
COMPONENT AS WELL --
THERE WAS A QUESTION ABOUT HOW
MANY LOCAL GRANTS WILL THE
PROPOSED LEVEL OF FUNDING BE
PROVIDED --
AND THAT REALLY WILL DEPEND ON
THE MAXIMUM GRANT AWARD THAT IS
AVAILABLE WE DO THIS ALL IN A
PUBLICALLY VETTED PROCESS SO WE
GET INFORMATION BACK FROM THE
PUBLIC THAT WILL ALLOW US TO
DETERMINE THE BEST WAY. TO CRAFT
THE GRANT PROGRAM --
TO ACCESS TO PROVIDE SUPPORT TO
AS MANY --
ENTITIES AND SUBMITTING AGENCIES
AS POSSIBLE SO THAT WILL BE AN
ON ON GOING PROCESS --
ADDITIONALLY --
WE DO ANTICIPATE --
FOR UPCOMING PROP SIXTY EIGHT
RELEASE THAT WE WILL HAVE --
PUBLIC SCHOOL OF PROPOSAL
SOLICITATION PACKAGE AND PLAN
RELEASED IN EARLY TWENTY TWENTY
IF THIS APPROACH APPROPRIATION
IS APPROVED --
SO THAT DOES TRIGGER THE FORTY
FIVE DAY PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD --
AND IF.
WITH PRIORITIZATION CRITERIA --
YOU VAST WHAT WILL BE USED FOR
ALLOCATING THOSE GRANTS A
SIMILAR TO THE MAXIMUM GRANT
AWARD -- THE
PRIVATIZATION CRITERIA WILL BE
DETERMINED --
THROUGH THIS PROCESS --
SORRY TO REPEAT MYSELF IS
COMMITTING ITS ATTENTION TO
CRITICALLY OVER DRAFTED BASINS
AND WAYS TO SUPPORT.
AND ASSIST DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES.
I DON'T WANNA GO INTO TOO MUCH
MORE DETAIL HOPEFULLY HAVE AN
OVERLOADED YOU I HAVE TRIED TO
ANSWER YOUR QUESTIONS I HAVE
MORE.
INFORMATION IF YOU NEED.
THANK YOU OVER OVERLOADING IS
WHAT THE SUBCOMMITTEE CELEBRATE --
I DO HAVE A QUESTION ABOUT THE
NINE POSITIONS THAT I THAT YOU
IDENTIFIED FOR US --
CIGNA -- AND
THEN THERE WERE TWO THERE WAS
TWENTY TWENTY AND TWENTY TWENTY
TWO I ASSUME THOSE POSITIONS ARE.
RELATED TO THE WORK THAT NEEDS
TO BE DONE.
FOR TWENTY TWENTY TWO IT'S IT'S
IN FACT FOR ALL OF FOR ALL OF
THE DEADLINES IS THE CRITICALLY
OVER DRAFTED BASIN PLANTS A
MIDDLE DEADLINE --
THE SOONER THAT WE CAN ACQUIRE
THOSE POSITIONS OF THE BETTER
BECAUSE WE DO NEED TO TRAIN
THOSE STAFF IT'S NOT SIMPLY A
HIT THE GROUND RUNNING --
PROCESS THESE ARE VERY DENSE UP
PLANS THAT WILL BE COMING TO US
SO -- THE
DEPARTMENT IS IS HOPING THAT THE
THIS REQUEST IN ITS APPROVAL
ALLOWS US TO BRING IN --
PROPERLY --
EXCUSE ME THE PROPER EXPERTISE
FROM STAFF WHERE WE CAN TRAIN
THEM TO THE PROGRAM --
AND THEN THEY CAN IMMEDIATELY
START WITH --
EVALUATIONS WELL THAT'S THE SORT
OF FOOT TOUCHES ON MY POINT OKAY --
IF -- AS WE
WILL APPROVED FOR THE THE BUDGET.
TO IF THE LEGISLATURE APPROVES
AND WE REACH AGREEMENT ON THE
BUDGET THAT'S NOT GONNA HAPPEN
UNTIL JUNE THEN YOU'RE GONNA
START YOUR HIRING PROCESS WHICH
TYPICALLY IS A A LOW RENT A
RATHER LENGTHY --
UP PROCESS AND THEY'RE GOING TO
TRAIN THOSE PEOPLE I JUST DON'T
SEE WHERE THIS GOING TO BE TIME
LEFT IN THE IN THE FOR THEM --
TO AT ADDRESS A IS WHERE MY RUN
ON THE THANK YOU CHAIR AS I
SHARE YOUR CONCERN --
ABOUT THE DEPARTMENTS READINESS
AND SO THAT'S WHAT MAKES THESE
POSITIONS ESSENTIAL WE ARE
WORKING WITH CALLIE CHAR WITH US
SECRETARY CROWFOOT.
AND I HAVE.
MET WITH THEM LAST WEEK --
TO DEVISE A WAY IN WHICH WE CAN
RECRUIT.
THE TALENT THAT WE NEED AS
EXPEDITIOUSLY AS POSSIBLE --
WE ARE ALSO LOOKING INTO
PARTNERSHIPS WITH THE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEMS AS APPROPRIATE TO BRING
ON A PARTICULAR EXPERTISE ONE OF
THE REAL CHALLENGES AS YOU MAY
BE AWARE IS --
FAIRLY SOPHISTICATED --
AMOUNT OF MODELING AND NEW
MODELING HAS BEEN DEVELOPED TO
SUPPORT THESE PLANS AND THE NEED
IS TO BRING.
ESSENTIALLY FILL THESE NEW
POSITIONS WITH THE MODELING
EXPERTISE THAT CAN ENABLE US TO
REVIEW THEM.
BUT WE ARE TURNING OVER EVERY
STONE TO ENSURE THAT WE CAN
BRING -- THE
EXPERTISE ON BOARD AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE AND THAT THE NINE
POSITIONS --
WE'RE REQUESTING AS PART OF OR A
PIECE OF THAT AN ESSENTIAL PIECE
OF THAT.
OKAY -- I I
I APPRECIATE THE RESPONSE --
I DON'T THINK WE'VE HAD A
MEETING.
YEAH AND MAYBE SOMETHING WE CAN.
DISCUSS IN MORE DETAILS OF THAT
I HAVE A BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF
HOW TO GET THEY WANT THE SUPPORT
OF THIS IS AN IMPORTANT WORK
THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE --
JUST OUTLINED IN LIMITED
QUESTION MISTER CHAIR JUST AS A
NOTE THERE HAVE BEEN POSITIONS
PROVIDED FOR SEGMENTAL
MEDITATION FOR PROPOSITION ONE
HAND IN THE CURRENT YEAR FUNDED
THROUGH PROPOSITION SIXTY EIGHT
TWO AND ON THE NUMBERS IN FRONT
OF ME I DON'T KNOW IF YOU ALL DO
BUT SO THIS.
IS THIS WOULD BE AN INCREASE
SENATE TURNING UP BUT THEY DO
HAVE SOME BASS STAFF THAT THE
LEGISLATURE IS ALREADY FUNDED
FOR THESE ACTIVITIES RIGHT BY I
THINK THAT DOESN'T.
QUITE AT THAT ADDRESS THE THE
CONCERNED AND A HALF SO IT'S NOT
EVEN SO MUCH A CONCERN AS JUST A
DESIRE TO UNDERSTAND --
INCREASED HAPPENED A TIMELY
FASHION TO ADDRESS THE ISSUES
THAT YOU WANT TO DEAL WITH
[inaudible]
MS RICE.
LIVES I ASSUME WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT ITEM NUMBER.
EIGHT AM I WRONG IN THE I EVEN
ISSHIN ISSUE NUMBER ISSUE NUMBER.
EIGHT THE KNOW WHERE --
I STILL IN ISSUE NUMBER.
ONE I'LL BE READY I PROMISE YOU
WILL GET THEIR THAT'S JUST BASED
ON IN THE HISTORY --
WILL GET THROUGH THE ENTIRE
REGION.
YES LET'S SO LET'S MOVE ON TO TO
PARKS.
YOU'RE THE THIRD BULLET POINT.
WE HAVE THAT CEDRIC MITCHELL
HERE FROM STATE PARKS GREAT AND
WHILE SHE'S --
WALKING UP OR JUST --
TAKE NOTE THAT --
WE HAVE A STAFF RECOMMENDATION
HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN SO WE'LL BE
ABLE -- TO A
HEARING [inaudible]
WELCOME.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS CEDRIC MITCHELL ON THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR A COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT FOR THE PARCHMENTS
GOOD TO SEE YOU ALL.
AND I WON THANK YOU FOR INVITING
US HERE TO TALK ABOUT PROP SIXTY
EIGHT IT'S A VERY EXCITING TIME --
I GUESS THE EASIEST THING TO DO
IS BEGIN BY TALKING ABOUT THE
LARGEST OF OUR PROGRAMS THE
STATE WHAT PART PROGRAM WHICH
HAS ABOUT TWO HUNDRED FORTY NINE
MILLION OF THE SIX HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION.
THAT HAS BEEN APPROPRIATED AS
CURRENTLY --
I THINK IT ALSO HELP --
BECAUSE THE QUESTIONS I'VE HEARD --
REGARDING ACCESS AND WE'RE GOING
TO ABILITY TO HAVE THE TO APPLY
FOR THE GRANTS NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED.
AND I CAN ADDRESS THAT BY
STARTING WITH ON SEPTEMBER FIFTH
WE STARTED THE PROCESS WHICH IS
CUSTOMARY WITH OUR DEPARTMENT.
TO TO ENGAGE IN FOCUS GROUPS AND
PUBLIC SESSIONS TO DEVELOP THE
GUIDELINES OF THOSE GUIDELINES --
INCLUDE --
PUBLIC HEARING HAD OVER THREE
HUNDRED PEOPLE ENGAGE IN THAT
PROCESS AS WE DEVELOP THE
GUIDELINE ITSELF --
IN FEBRUARY OF THIS YEAR WE MADE
PUBLIC THE FINAL GUIDELINE --
THE GUIDELINE --
HAS A DEADLINE OF AUGUST FIFTH.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN FOR
TURNING IN YOUR APPLICATIONS.
AND SINCE THAT TIME WE ALSO HAD
A SERIES OF OF BOB TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE WORKSHOPS --
WHICH WE CONCLUDED AS ACTUALLY
AS OF FRIDAY --
WHERE WE HAD OVER --
FIVE HUNDRED THIRTEEN
INDIVIDUALS FROM AGENCIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THOSE APPLICATION WORKSHOPS ARE
DESIGNED SO THAT INDIVIDUALS CAN
EASILY UNDERSTAND WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING --
FOR BEAR SIX OUR WORKSHOPS
INCLUDING ON THE PAGE BY PAGE
LIES IN THE TOOLS TIME THE
STATIONS TO HAVE THE TO A THE
STATE IS YOUR WHERE IS AN
EXTENSION OF PROPERTY.
FOR AND PROPERTY FOR WE HAD TWO
ROUNDS IN THAT PARTICULAR
PROGRAM --
WE HAD NEARLY THREE BILLION
DOLLARS IN REQUEST OVER NINE
HUNDRED APPLICATIONS CAME TO US --
FROM THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND
WE'RE ABLE TO FUND OVER HUNDRED
NEW PARKS AS WELL AS DOZENS OF
OTHER PARK IMPROVEMENTS AND
EXPANSIONS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
OUR HOPE IS THAT WE'LL SEE THE
SAME LEVEL OF COMPETITION.
WAS SEALED SAME LEVEL OF
INTEREST GIVEN THAT WE'VE HAD
OVER FIVE HUNDRED THAT HAVE
PARTICIPATED --
JUSTIN OUR TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
WORKSHOPS BUT OUR OUTREACH
EFFORTS COLLECTIVELY INCLUDING --
THOSE PUBLIC MEETINGS AND
HEARINGS ADDITIONALLY WE DO
WE'VE HAD CONFERENCE CALLS WITH
A NEW DOZENS OF AGENCIES ON
FACILITATED. FOR US --
HAVE BEEN OVER A THOUSAND JUST
SINCE SEPTEMBER OF THIS YEAR OF
SEPTEMBER OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN SO
THE GOAL THAT WE HAVE IS CLEARLY --
A COMMUNITY FOCUSED PROCESS THAT
REQUIRES AGENCIES TO ENGAGE WITH
THE PEOPLE WERE GOING TO LIVE
WITH THE PUT PROS PROJECTS THAT
ARE GOING TO BE TO BE IN THE
COMMUNITIES --
ULTIMATELY --
OUR EXPECTATION IS THAT WE WILL
HAVE ADDITIONAL TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE WORKSHOPS AVAILABLE
TO PEOPLE AS WELL --
WE PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AND SEVERAL OTHER WAYS.
ALL APPLICANTS A POTENTIAL
APPLICANTS CAN CONTACT THE
PROJECT OFFICERS AND OUR STAFF
DIRECTLY WE ARE OUR PHONE
NUMBERS ARE PUBLISHED ON OUR
WEBSITE.
YOU CAN ASK ANY QUESTIONS --
THAT THEY WOULD LIKE --
REGARDING --
REGARDING THE THE APPLICATIONS --
THEY CAN ALSO CONTACT US BY
EMAIL THEY CAN ALSO AS WE GET
CLOSER TO THE DEADLINE WITH
WEIRD LIKELY IT IS CUSTOMARY
WITH OUR DEPARTMENT TO HAVE. ONE
IN ONE OPPORTUNITIES WILL BE IN
THE REGION AND THEY CAN COME AND
WE CAN CHECK THE COMPLETENESS OF
THEIR APPLICATIONS.
SO AS FAR AS THE STATE WHY PARK
PROGRAM THE CORE OF THAT PROGRAM
WE ARE WELL UNDER WAY --
THERE'S BEEN --
BUT AMPLE AND ENGAGEMENT AND OUR
HOPE IS THAT WE WILL SEE A
RECORD NUMBER FOR US OF
APPLICATIONS THAT WILL BE
[inaudible]
PROCESS.
CONTAINED WITHIN THE STATE WHY
PART PROGRAM IS A COMMITTEE
ACCESS PROGRAM.
THROUGH THE COURSE OF OUR PUBLIC
MEETINGS AND HEARINGS AND THE
FEEDBACK THAT WE RECEIVED OUR
AND WRITTEN WRITTEN FORM.
WE DECIDED --
TO HAVE THE THE PROGRAM BE A
SEPARATE EFFORT --
IS A STANDALONE PROGRAM WE'RE
LOOKING AT PROPOSING RIGHT NOW --
SEVENTEEN MILLION IN THE FIRST
ROUND WILL LOOK AT THAT AS A
PILOT BECAUSE THIS IS NEVER BEEN
DONE WITH BOND MONEY BEFORE.
ON WE'VE HAD A SERIES OF FOCUS
GROUPS THAT WE'VE HAD
APPROXIMATELY EIGHTY OR SO --
PEOPLE HELPING US TO CRAFT WHAT
ARE THE VISION FOR THIS
PARTICULAR PROGRAM WILL BE --
WE'RE GOING TO BE CONCLUDING
THAT IN COMING UP WITH A DRAFT
FOR THE PUBLIC WITHIN THE NEXT
THREE WEEKS OR SO.
AT THAT POINT WE'LL HAVE IT OUT
PUBLICLY LOOKING AT HOW THAT.
THAT DOCUMENT CAN BE IMPROVED
AND ULTIMATELY WE PLAN ON HAVING
THE PROGRAM AVAILABLE TO THE
PUBLIC AND APPLICATIONS STARTING
IN THE LATE SPRING --
ITS IT'S SO IN THOSE TWO
PROGRAMS I THINK I'LL STOP AT
THIS POINT AND IF THERE ARE ANY
QUESTIONS I'D BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
[inaudible]
AS WITH.
AT FIRST I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
FOR BEING HERE BUT ALSO YOUR
PRESENCE AND SANDRA DINO --
IT IN HELPING MY COMMUNITY HAVE
BETTER ACCESS YOU WERE VERY
IMPORTANT VERY INSTRUMENTAL IN
THE COMMUNITY WAS --
MOST APPRECIATIVE OF THE
ATTENTION NOT JUST THE WORDS
THAT ARE SAID ABOUT WE WANT
ACCESS.
BUT THE ACTIONS --
YOUR GREAT REPRESENTATIVE AND I
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
THE QUESTION WAS ASKED EARLIER
BY MY COLLEAGUE AND I QUESTIONED
ALSO.
ON THE COMMUNITY ACCESS OPPOSE
IT WILL BE FOR SEVENTEEN MILLION
IS A STILL STAND ALONE.
YES IT IS SO AND HOW WILL HOW
WILL YOU BE ABLE --
TO BUT IF IT IF WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT EQUITY THEM WHAT'S THE
PROCESS GOING TO BE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT ALL OF THE THE AREAS
THAT MOST NEED ACCESS OR THE
ONES THAT DO GET IT.
THAT'S VERY GOOD QUESTION --
IN COURT TO THIS WHOLE EFFORT
HAS TO BE ON WE HAVE TO STICK
BUT TAKE A STEP AWAY FROM
BUSINESS AS USUAL THIS SHOULD
NOT BE SEEN.
AS SIMPLY FUNDING ORGANIZATIONS
TO DO WITH THE CURRENTLY DOING
WE START WITH THE PREMISE THAT.
IF WE WERE ABLE TO DO TO DO MORE
OF WHAT WE'VE ALREADY BEEN DOING
THE MOVIE WE WOULD BE SUCCESSFUL
IN NOT HAVING THIS CONVERSATION.
IT'S AUTOMATICALLY WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT IS NEW AND CREATIVE
CREATIVE WAYS OF ENGAGING THAT
WILL INCLUDE --
HAVING THINGS SUCH AS A HOME
BASE MAKING CERTAIN THAT THEIR
ACTIVITIES NOT JUST THE WAY BUT
THAT PEOPLE WERE ULTIMATELY IN
ORGANIZATIONS COMING TO
COMMUNITIES.
THERE ARE A COUPLE THINGS THAT
WE LOOK FOR IN OUR PROCESS
THERE'S TWO THINGS THAT SHOULD
HAPPEN AND WE ASKED A LOT OF OUR
APPLICANTS BUT WE STAND SIDE BY
SIDE WITH THEM THROUGH THE
PROCESS.
AND THE TWO THINGS THAT WE HAVE
FOUND THAT HAPPEN OR ARE THESE
ONE DAY EITHER RECEIVE A GRANT
BUT ULTIMATELY TRANSFORMS OUR
COMMUNITY BECAUSE WE INSIST ON
AUGUST.
DODD IN DEPTH COMMUNITY ENGAGE
PROCESS.
OR TO THE COMMUNITY WILL BECOME
CIVIC CONTRAST FROM THE
PARTICULAR COMMUNITIES.
BY DEVELOPING --
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THEIR LOCAL
PROVIDERS THAT INCLUDES NON
PROFITS AND THAT INCLUDES PUBLIC
AGENCIES SO AS WE LOOK AT THIS
PARTICULAR PROGRAM.
IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT WHAT CAN WE
DO FOR YOU IT'S ULTIMATELY HOW
ARE THE PROGRAM'S GOING TO
TRANSFORM THOSE PARTICULAR
COMMUNITIES BECAUSE ACCESS IS
NOT JUST THE WAY IT'S ALSO AT
HOME.
AND ULTIMATELY THE PEOPLE NEED
TO BE ABLE TO LIVE WITH THE
PROJECTS THAT ARE GOING TO BE
THERE AND HAVE BENEFIT THAT THAT
THAT -- FROM
THESE DOLLARS THAT WILL ALLOW
FOR THEM TO HAVE AN ON GOING
RELATIONSHIP WITH NATURE WHETHER
THAT BE THROUGH ACTIVE
RECREATION OR WHETHER IT BE
THROUGH OPEN SPACES.
SO STARTING WITH THAT PREMISE
WE'RE CHALLENGING NON PROFITS
AND PUBLIC AGENTS AGENCIES IN
HELPING US TO DEVELOP THIS
PROGRAM.
THAT IT'S ONE THAT WILL BE
LOOKED UPON HOPEFULLY AS A MODEL
FOR THE NATION AND NOT JUST
BUSINESS AS USUAL.
ULTIMATELY WE HAVE TO DEFINE AND
EVALUATE THE EFFECTIVENESS
THAT'S WHY WE'RE NOT PUTTING
FORTH THE ENTIRE THIRTY TWO
MILLION WHAT WE'RE SAYING IS
WITH THE FIRST SEVENTEEN MILLION
OF THIS WHICH WE NEED --
TO LIQUIDATE WITHIN BY TWENTY
TWENTY TWO SO DOING THAT AND AND
IDENTIFYING ORGANIZATIONS THAT
HAVE THE CAPACITY TO SHIFT WHAT
THEY'RE DOING.
IS WHY WE'RE STARTING AS AS THE
PRO AS THE MODEL AND THEN THE
DIGITAL FUNDS WILL LOOK AT AND
SEE IF WE NEED TO EXPAND ON
PROGRAMMING OR WHETHER WE NEED.
TO CREATE SOMETHING COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT THAT MAKES MISSION IF
YOU FOLLOW THE PROCESS HE'S WITH
ALL OF OUR PROGRAMS WHAT WE'VE
SEEN IS A DISTRIBUTION THAT HAS
A NATURAL ORGANIC AFFECT.
WE DON'T GO INTO THE BUSINESS OF
TRYING -- TO
MANIPULATE THAT PROCESS
ULTIMATELY WHAT YOU'VE SEEN IF
YOU LOOK AT PROP --
EIGHTY FOUR THE STATE MY PROGRAM
IF YOU LOOKED AT THE
DISTRIBUTION THAT OCCURRED YOU
SEE PROJECTS THAT WENT AS FAR
NORTH AS READING AS FAR SOUTH AS
SAN DIEGO AND OUT INTO THE AND
THEN.
INTO THE COACHELLA VALLEY
ACCESSORY.
ULTIMATELY --
COMMUNITY ENGAGE PROCESS WHICH
WERE VERY PROUD TO BE PIONEER
HAS HAS BEEN PROVEN OVER THE
LAST FIFTEEN YEARS TO BE AN
EFFECTIVE METHOD FOR REGION
ENGAGING COMMITTED. TWENTY
STATEWIDE.
IT DOESN'T TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION THE THE POLITICAL
FORCES IT DOES HOWEVER TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION THE THE THE MERITS
OF THE PROJECT.
THE SITUATIONS OF INDIVIDUAL
COMMUNITIES AND INSIST THAT
THERE BE --
MEETINGS THAT REFLECT THEIR
THEIR VISIONS. FOR THE FIRST
TIME UNDER PROPERTY FOR AND THE
FIRST TIME IN AND WE BELIEVE IN
STATE HISTORY.
OVER FOUR THOUSAND MEETINGS TOOK
PLACE IN COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE
BEEN UNDERSERVED AND FORGOTTEN.
THOSE FOUR THOUSAND MEETINGS
INCLUDED MULTIPLE MEETINGS THAT
STARTED WITH AND CASES IN SOME
CASES WITH BUTCHER PAPER AND
JUST IDEAS AND ULTIMATELY BECAME
PROJECTS THAT PEOPLE ARE LIVING
AND ENGAGING. ONE OF THE TOOLS
THAT WE ARE LOOKING AT THAT SIT
SAYS THAT THIS PROCESS SEEMS TO
WORK IS A COMMUNITIES ALSO IN
THE SAME TIME FRAME BEGAN TO TAX
THEMSELVES AND ULTIMATELY GIVE
FEES TO THEMSELVES. FOR PROJECTS
THAT WEREN'T FUNDED BUT
ULTIMATELY ARE BECOMING FUNDED
BECAUSE THE COMMUNITIES ARE
ENGAGED IN THAT CIVIC PROCESS.
SO WE COULD TAKE FULL CREDIT FOR
THAT BUT SEEMS TO BE WORKING AS
EVIDENCED BY WHAT YOU'RE SEEING
WITH -- WITH
PROJECTS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
THIS MON.
THING WAS CHAIR TO ONE OF THE
LABOR THIS ITEM TOO MUCH HERE
BUT THIS PARTICULAR INTEREST IN
THIS IS A QUESTION FOR NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY AND NOT SURE
THE APPROPRIATE STAFF.
FOR BUT MULTI BENEFIT STORM
WATER PROJECTS.
ARE OF A PARTICULAR INTEREST --
IN MY AREA THE CITY COUNTY
ASSOCIATION OF GOVERNMENTS IN
SAN MATEO COUNTY IS INTERESTED
IN THE STORM WATER RENO I GUESS
THERE'S NINETY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS ALLOCATED OUT OF THE
BOND FOR THAT IN THAT LINE ITEM.
NOT A LOT OF DETAIL ON WHAT THE
DESIGNS ARE WHAT THE PLANS ARE
FOR THAT NINETY THREE MILLION.
I DON'T KNOW IF THE APPROPRIATE
PERSONS HERE TO SPEAK TO THAT IF
NOT WE GETS REALLY FOLLOW UP --
OFFLINE BUT ANY GUIDANCE --
THAT'S JUST OF A PARTICULAR --
INTEREST TO FOLKS MY DISTRICT
THE PROGRAMS ARE BEING SITE
YOU'LL SEE --
PROGRESS THROUGH THE GUIDELINE
PROCESS THERE'S GOING TO BE
PUBLIC OUTREACH TO COMMUNITIES
THERE'S GOING TO BE WORKSHOPS SO
WE'RE GONNA FALL OR NOBLE
PROCESS AND DEVELOPING THE
PROGRAM BUT THE EMPHASIS ON
MULTI BENEFIT STORM WATER
PROJECTS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK GOD THAT BRINGS US TO THE
CONCLUSION OF SHE WON I THINK
THE I THINK THE REMAINING ANGELS
ARE PROBABLY MOVE FOR A A LITTLE
MORE QUICKLY BUT THIS ONE WAS
MORE OF A AN IN DEPTH --
DIVE INTO THIS PARTICULAR --
AREAS -- I
THINK WHAT WE'LL DO IS TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT ON ON THIS ISSUE
NOW -- AT
AND THEN --
DO PUBLIC COMMENT DEPARTMENT BY
DEPARTMENT AS OPPOSED TO ISSUE
BY ISSUE --
BUT THIS --
ONE IS IS SO BROAD AND SO BIG I
THINK IT'S A GOOD TIME --
TO TO PAUSE.
AND TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT.
THANK YOU MISTER AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE --
INTO THE RESOURCES AGENTS
SECRETARY --
ANALYST AFTER HERE.
SINCE THIS ITEM WAS A LONG ONE I
THINK IT'S AN A NEW WAY OF
APPROACHING THE PROP SIXTY EIGHT
DISCUSSION I HOPE THAT IN THE
UPCOMING HEARINGS AS OF THE
DEPARTMENTS AND AGENCIES GOT 2% --
WE CAN REVISIT SOME OF THE PROP --
SIXTY EIGHT ITEMS JUST. TO TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE THAT DISCUSSION SO
YOU WILL HEAR FROM ME RIGHT NOW
SOME A LONGER COMMENT THEN THAT
YOU WOULD OTHERWISE HAVE HEARD
OVER.
A NUMBER OF HEARINGS SO PLEASE
BEAR WITH ME --
OF FEDERAL AND ON BEHALF OF
LEVINE TO TO REALLY EMPHASIZE
AND THANK THE SECRETARY FOR HIS
COMMENTS A AROUND HIS INTENTION --
TO TO RELIEVE PRIORITIZE ACCESS
ACCESS TO THE OUTDOORS ACCESS TO
PARKS -- AS
A CORE COMPONENT OF ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT HE REALLY WANTS TO
BE FOCUSED ON THAT'S REALLY
GREAT TO HEAR --
WITH REGARD TO TO PROP SIXTY
IMPLEMENTATION AS THE MEMBERS OF
BACK OF THE COMMITTEE HAVE HAVE
HIGHLIGHTED.
THAT THE ISSUE OF COMMUNITY
ACCESS IS ONE THAT IS IS IS
BRAND NEW AS WAS.
MENTIONED BY THE SECRETARY AND
BY THE DEPARTMENT --
AND ONE THAT NEEDS TO BE --
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE --
ARE CAREFULLY CRAFTED SO THAT IT
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF IT IS
ACTUALLY MEETING GOALS AND
OBJECTIVES ARE SET OUT IN PROP --
SIXTY EIGHT AND AT THIS POINT
THEY'RE THEY'RE A LOT OF
EXAMPLES STATE PARKS HAS BEEN
DOING A PHENOMENAL JOB CENTER
CAN HIS TEAM AND AND ALL THE
WORKSHOPS THAT HE'S BEEN HOSTING
UP AND DOWN THE THE STATE --
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO TO ENCAPSULATE
THE THE GENERAL SENTIMENT OF OF
RESIDENTS AND NGOS AND LOCAL
AGENCIES AND REALLY DONE A GREAT
JOB OF HEARING THEM OUT.
AND THEREFORE DEVELOPING --
THIS NEW PROPOSED APPROACH ON A
ON A STANDALONE COMMUNITY ACCESS
PROGRAM I'M SURE CENTER PROBABLY
FEEL LIKE I'VE BEEN STALKING HIM.
BECAUSE I'VE BEEN ABLE TO ATTEND
A GOOD NUMBER THESE JUST A
WITNESS THE WAY IN WHICH THE THE
DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN ACTING ARE
OR CONDUCTING THESE THESE
WORKSHOPS --
THEM IN THE COAST CONSERVANCY
ARE ARE TO THAT THAT REALLY COME
OUT AS AS TO AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS THAT ARE THAT ARE
APPROACHING THIS IN THE RIGHT
WAY.
WE WE DO AGREE THAT WE HAVE SOME
CONCERN I'M NOT INCLUDING EVEN A
REFERENCE TO COMMUNITY ACCESS
AND IN THE GUIDELINES --
OR EVEN IF THEY DO IN DOING SO
IN A VERY --
GENERAL MANNER THAT REALLY
DOESN'T --
DOESN'T ARTICULATE WHAT THE
DEPARTMENTS OF PERSPECTIVE IS ON
HOW COMMUNITY ACCESS IS ACTUALLY
GONNA BE DEVELOPED TO INCLUDING
GAUGE WHEN PROGRAMS.
AND IT AND THAT AND GREAT AND
BRINGS ME TO THE THE SECOND
POINT WHICH IS AROUND ENGAGEMENT
PROGRAMS --
ABSOLUTELY AGREE THAT --
TYPICALLY --
CAPITAL OUTLAY HAS BEEN THE
PRIMARY FOCUS OF GEO BONDS --
BUT THE LEGISLATURE VERY
INTENTIONALLY WROTE PROP --
SIXTY EIGHT WITH AN EQUITY FOCUS
AND AND THAT EQUITY FOCUS IS
WHAT DROVE THEM TO INCLUDE THIS
5% PROVISION --
TO ALLOW FOR COMMUNITY ACCESS
PROJECTS THAT INCLUDING GIVEN
PROGRAMS BECAUSE WE ALL
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THOSE ARE
CRITICAL TO GETTING SPECIALLY
FOLKS WILL DISMISS COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE --
LESS RESOURCES TAKE TO GET OUT
TO THESE PLACES ON TO BE ABLE TO
DO SO AND ENJOY THESE THESE
INVESTMENTS THAT WE'RE MAKING AS
A STATE --
JUST AS MUCH AS BOOKS FROM MORE
AFFLUENT COMMUNITIES CAN.
AND SO IN INDIA IN.
YOU KNOW KIND OF A FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE FROM THE OUTSIDE
LOOKING IN I THINK --
ADDITIONAL CLARITY IN DISCUSSION
BETWEEN THE LEGISLATURE IT'S AND
FOLKS AT THAT THE AGENCY --
WILL HOPEFULLY PROVIDE THAT
CLARITY ABOUT WHAT WAS ACTUALLY
INTENDED --
WHEN IT COMES TO ENGAGE IN
PROGRAMS AND AND HOW IT WAS
WRITTEN --
BY THE AUTHORS AND BY THE
DIFFERENT MEMBERS THAT ENGAGE IN
THAT PROCESS TO TO PROVIDE THAT --
THAT RESOLUTION HOPEFULLY THIS
YEAR.
AND THEN CEDRIC MENTIONED --
THE LIQUIDATION PERIOD FOR THE
COMMUNITY ACCESS PROGRAM --
FOR THIS FIRST ROUND THAT WAS
APPROPRIATE LAST YEAR OF TWENTY
TWENTY TWO WHICH RAISES IT'S
MORE LIKE A TECHNICAL ISSUE
AROUND ENCUMBRANCE PERIODS AND
AND HOW QUICKLY THE PROJECT
COMPLETION NEEDS TO BE TURNED
OVER.
AND AND COMPLETED --
SO ONE SUGGESTION THAT THAT WE
HAVE BEEN CONSIDERING ARE
DISCUSSING IS --
AROUND ALLOWING FOR AN
ENCUMBRANCE --
PERIOD ADJUSTMENT TO ALLOW FOR
ONE OR TWO MORE YEARS --
SPECIFIC TO THE COMMUNITY ACTS --
PROVISIONS IT IS A KNOWING THAT
THERE ARE A LOT OF GREAT
PROJECTS OUT THERE THEY'RE READY
TO BE. TO GET MOVED ON BUT FOR
THIS COMMUNITY AXIS PEACE AS THE
GUIDELINES ARE STILL BEING
DEVELOPED IN THIS NEXT YEAR --
UNDER WITH THE UNDERSTANDING
THAT THE GRANTS WILL LIKELY NOT
GO OUT UNTIL NEXT YEAR --
WANTING TO SEE THAT ADDRESSED IS
IS A PRIORITY --
MORE BROADLY TO THOUGH --
YOU KNOW AN EARLY DISCUSSIONS
WHEN THE PROPOSAL CAME OUT IN
JANUARY --
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION THERE
WAS DISCUSSION ABOUT --
A ENSURING THAT PROP SIXTY EIGHT
IS IS NOT AN EXCUSE TO SUPPLANT
OTHER --
FUNDING FOR NATURAL RESOURCES
AND PARKS ISSUES --
THAT THE VOTERS IN THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVED PROP SIXTY
EIGHT AS ADDITIONAL TO WHAT IS --
CURRENTLY BEING INVESTED BY THE
STATE FOR ALL THESE GREAT
RESOURCES --
AND THEREFORE WANTED TO TO KIND
OF HARKEN BACK TO A COUPLE YEARS
AGO TO AN IDEA THAT HAVE BEEN
PROPOSED BY THEN SECRETARY --
LAYERED --
ABOUT.
IT AND AT THE ESTABLISHED
DURATION FUND WHICH IS THERE
IT'S IN THE STATUTE.
AND WE WE BELIEVE IT'S USEFUL AS
A DISCUSSION POINT WHERE THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION CAN COME TOGETHER
TO IDENTIFY ADDITIONAL
PRIORITIES.
THAT CAN BE FUNDED THROUGH THE
NOT JUST BOND FUNDS --
BUT THROUGH OTHER FUN SOURCES
INCLUDING POTENTIALLY YOU KNOW
GENERAL FUND AND AND OTHER
SPECIAL FUNDS --
CAN CAN YOU WRAP UP YES --
AND LASTLY I JUST WANT TO
MENTION ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
RELIEF ON THE JORDAN FORESTRY
THAT WHEN IT COMES TO PROP SIXTY
EIGHT THEY IF THE FULL
PREPARATION FOR URBAN FORESTRY
WAS DONE IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET --
AND THEY EXPECT TO METABOLIZE
THAT COMPLETELY AND IN THE NEXT
YEAR -- AND
THAT'S ONE OF THE EXAMPLES OF
WHERE THERE IS AN ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENT BEING PROPOSED --
ANYWHERE ELSE IN THE BUDGET --
FOR FOR URBAN FORESTRY --
WHETHER THROUGH YOUR AFTER OTHER
FUN SOURCES SO ONE OF THE REYES
ACTEDAS A CONCERN AND WE WILL
BE BACK TO TO CONTINUE THE
DISCUSSION ON THAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WANT TO MEET ON A
WITHOUT A BY CALIFORNIA.
FIRST OFF I WANNA ECHO --
WITH THE PREVIOUS SPEAKER'S
COMMENTS --
RELATED --
THAT NOTION.
ON THE NATURAL RESOURCES WHILE
WE ARE SUPPORT THE CONCEPT OF
IDEA OF STAFFING UP D. W. R. --
TO IMPLEMENT SIGMA WE WOULD LIKE
TO SEE ADDITIONAL DETAIL TO THIS
PROPOSAL --
WE WILL FURTHER ADD THAT FUNDING.
THAT FUNDING.
BE ALLOCATED FOR STAFFING
POSITIONS AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE OR SEGMENT
PLANTATION AS WELL --
THE CURRENT NUMBER POSITIONS
THAT ARE AT DFW ARE RELATED TO
SIGNAL IS --
ARTS SIGNIFICANTLY UNDERSTAFFED --
AND AS YOU'VE HEARD THERE'S
CLEARLY A SIGNIFICANT A NUMBER
OF WORK LOAD INCREASES THAT WILL
BE SEEN AND WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE
THAT REFLECTED AS WELL.
AT AT THE F. W. --
BECAUSE THIS ISSUE IS NOT
NECESSARILY --
AND THE NEXT.
ITEM TO BE HEARD --
DFW AT LARGE AYE WE BELIEVE
SHOULD --
THERE SHOULD BE.
A DISCUSSION ABOUT HAVING ONE
TIME ALLOCATION MONEY FOR THE
DEPARTMENT TO DO --
TO CONTINUE DO ITS JOB
EFFECTIVELY SO --
THE SERVICE BAY IS SERVICE BASED
BUDGETING PROCESS WE UNDERSTAND
THAT THE LEGISLATURE APPROPRIATE
A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF MONEY.
TO COVER A PORTION OF THEIR
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT BUT WE
BELIEVE THAT THE DEPARTMENT HAS
A NUMBER OF AREAS THAT ARE STILL
THERE THEY'RE STILL RESPONSIBLE
FOR ADMINISTERING OR ENFORCING.
LIKE LIKE CIGNA OR WILDLIFE
ENFORCEMENT.
AS SUCH WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE
CONTINUED INVESTMENTS IN THAT.
IN THAT DEPARTMENT --
LIKE THE PREVIOUS SPEAKER SAID
WE WANT TO REINFORCE THE NOTION
THAT THE BUDGET PROCESS STILL AS
PROP BUDGET PROCESS
DELIBERATIONS CONTINUE --
THAT FUNDING --
THAT THAT APPROPRIATIONS FROM
PROP SIX CA SHOULD BE ADDITIVE
TO NATURAL RESOURCES AND NOT.
BE A WAY TO SUPPLANT --
YOU KNOW WHAT WE SHOULD BE
INVESTING IN --
IN THE STATE THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS PUBLIC GARCIA WITH
ENVIRONMENT DEFENSE FIND ANYONE
SPEAK TO TWO ITEMS THAT YOU
RECEIVE PRESENTATIONS ON AND I
WILL ENDEAVOR TO BE BRIEF --
FIRST ON VOLUNTARY AGREEMENTS
DIRECTOR BONHAM ND DIRECTING
THEM AS DESCRIBED THE PROCESS
AND YOU WHAT THAT IS ABOUT VERY
WELL AND ANGRY WITH WHAT THEY
YOU THEIR DESCRIPTION.
AND I THINK --
YOU'RE IN BERMAN RELATIONS
INVOLVED IN THIS PROCESS FOR
OVER TWO YEARS NOW AND I THINK
WE ARE.
LIKE IT'S HAS A LOT OF GOOD
MOMENTUM --
IMPORTANT MILESTONE IS REACHED
LAST FRIDAY BUT THE CEMENT
OVERDRAFT --
PROPOSAL TO THE WATER BOARD FOR
EVALUATION.
AND WE'RE OPTIMISTIC AND HOPEFUL
THAT BY THE IN THE YEAR WILL
HAVE A GOOD AGREEMENT THAT WE
CAN ALL GET BEHIND AND IT AND I
THINK -- THE
SEVENTY MILLION I THINK YOU'RE
ASKING THE RIGHT QUESTIONS IT'S
A LITTLE BIT NONSPECIFIC.
BECAUSE OF THE UNCERTAINTY
AROUND AGREEMENT BUT I HAVE SEEN
THE PROJECT WAS THAT DIRECTOR
NEMETH REFERENCED.
IT'S PRETTY LONG AND SINCE
THERE'S A LOT OF DIFFERENT
OPTIONS AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT HAVE.
THE SEVENTY MILLION AVAILABLE
ASSUMING AN AGREEMENT COMES
TOGETHER TO BEGIN WORK
IMMEDIATELY --
PART OF THE AGREEMENT IS FUNDING
FROM THE WATER USERS AS WELL SO
BUT IT WON'T THAT THOSE FUNDS
WILL TRUE OVER TIME THEY WON'T
BE IMMEDIATELY AVAILABLE AND I
THINK PART OF WHY A LOT OF A
SUPPORT OF VOLUNTARY AGREEMENT
IS BECAUSE WE CAN START.
TAKING ACTION AND IT SOON AS
IT'S DONE IMMEDIATELY AND I
THINK SO --
I THINK YOU HAVE THE RIGHT TO
ASK QUESTIONS BUT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT APPROPRIATIONS --
SECONDLY I WANT TO SPEAK TO A
SUSTAINABLE GROUNDWATER FROM ONE
WITH OUT OF MIND THAT YOU.
THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT BOTH
THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES AND APARTMENT FISH AND
WILDLIFE NEED MORE STAFF TO DEAL
WITH THE DAY LOSE OF WORK COMING
THEIRWAY --
THE MISS ROSIE ANY OUTLINE
WHAT'S COMING THE PLAN REVIEW --
SO I THINK YOU'RE THERE BOTH
TEAMS ARE LEAN AND MEAN AND
THEY'RE DOING A GREAT JOB WITH.
THE RESOURCES THEY HAVE WITH
AGAIN THE A LOT MORE AND IT'S
NOT.
THERE'S A PLAN REVIEW BUT IT'S
ALSO JUST AN ONGOING NEED.
THE ANNUAL REPORTS THE FIVE YEAR
REPORT AND I THINK YOU HAVE IT
EDF AS PART OF A GROUP CALLED
THE GROUND WATER LEADERSHIP FORM
THAT'S COMMITTED TO SUCCESSFUL
IMPLEMENTATION OF SIGNAL BECAUSE
WE SEE THIS AS ONE MOST
IMPORTANT INITIATIVES TO MAKE
THE STATE MORE CLIMATE RESILIENT.
I THINK YOU'RE ASKING THE RIGHT
QUESTIONS WE NEED WE DO NEED
MORE STAFF BUT YOU NEED MORE
DETAIL ON THE PROPOSAL --
AND I I JUST GIVEN THE LONG TERM
[inaudible]
YOU MIGHT IS TO START BUT YOU'RE
GONNA NEED ADDITION YOUR OTHER
RESOURCES AND PROBABLY GENERAL
FUND TO SUPPORT THAT PROGRAM.
GOING FORWARD AGAIN IT'S TWENTY
YEARS POTENTIALLY THIRTY YEARS.
AND MY JOB IS ALWAYS KNOWING CAN
RETIRE SO EVERYBODY STICK AROUND
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THE CONTRACTS ABOUT THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY --
ASSOCIATE MY COMMENTS MISTER
GARZA EDF PARTICULAR WITH REGARD
TO THE VOLUNTARY SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENTS THAT WE APPRECIATE.
THE WORK OF DIRECTOR BOTTOM AND
DRESSED IN A MESS ON THAT ISSUE
AND WE HAVE BEEN AT THE TABLE AS
WELL IN THIS PROCESS AND LOOK
FOR A SUCCESSFUL.
RESOLUTION OUTCOME I THINK
THAT'S HEADED WE'RE HEADED THAT
DIRECTION OF COURSE.
BUT ALSO HERE TO TODAY --
TO SUPPORT SAY SIR A COUPLE
THINGS ABOUT PROP SIXTY EIGHT I
MEAN CERTAINLY THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY STRONG SUPPORTERS OF
PROP.
SIXTY EIGHT I ALSO OF COURSE
THOUGH AND AS PREVIOUSLY STRONG
SUPPORTER OF IT --
BOTH AN EXPEDITIOUS AND THOROUGH
IMPLEMENTATION OF SIGMA AND I
THINK THAT --
WE WE CERTAINLY SUPPORT THE
PROPOSED B. C. P. REGARDING
SIGNIN PLANTATION BUT I THINK WE
ARE REALLY APPRECIATE OF THE
QUESTIONS RAISED IN THE ANALYSIS.
ALSO BY THE LA --
WITH REGARD.
TO THE NEW POSITIONS ADDITIONAL
POSITIONS BOTH A DEED OF YOUR
BUT ALSO THE DEPARTMENT FISH AND
WILDLIFE AS MENTIONED BY
AND
CERTAINLY WILLING TO WORK I
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH --
THE LEGISLATURE CERTAINLY IN AND
AND THE STATE'S OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING THE
DEPARTMENTS TO HEAR HOW WE GET
THE RESOURCES TO MAKE THAT
HAPPEN BUT I APPRECIATE YOUR
TIME TODAY THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS RECALL MONSTER TO NOT A
WITH THE TRUST FOR PUBLIC LAND.
I WANNA STRONGLY AFFILIATE OUR
POSITION IN MY REMARKS WITH THE
FOR SPEAKER MISTER ARE DANDO
WITH REGARD TO EQUITY ACCESS AND
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT I REALLY
APPRECIATE.
THE REMARKS FROM ASSEMBLYMEMBER
REYES HAND REAVIS TO TO THOSE
POINTS.
ANA I'M ALSO --
ECHO THE CONCERN ABOUT
LIQUIDATING THE MONEY FOR THE
NEIGHBORHOOD PARK PROGRAM BY
TWENTY TWENTY TWO I THINK.
OF THE MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES THAT THIS MONEY IS
INTENDED FOR IT TO ACHIEVE
EQUITY IN ACCESS ARE GONNA HAVE
A REALLY HARD TIME FINISHING
PROJECTS.
IN THAT TIME FRAME SO I HOPE WE
CAN REVISIT --
YOU KNOW THE DEADLINE TO RID --
LIQUIDATE THOSE FUNDS MY FINAL
COMMENT IS THESE VERY SAME
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE PARK POOR.
ARE ALSO THE MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES THE CLIMATE CHANGE
PARTICULARLY SHEET.
AND FLOODING SO I DON'T WANT THE
LEGISLATURE TO OIL OR THE
ADMINISTRATION A LOOK AT THE
PROP SIXTY EIGHT INVESTMENTS AS
A ASA PLANTING OF THE THE WITH A
A A A RESOURCE AGENCY AND OTHER
PROGRAMS --
THEY'RE VERY IMPORTANT TO
ACHIEVING OUR CLIMATE CALLS AS
WELL.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS READ
OUT US WITH COMMUNITY NATURE
CONNECTION AND FRIENDS A LOS
ANGELES RIVER WELL VERY
INTERESTED IN THE CONVERSATION
RAN COMMUNITY ACCESS TODAY.
ARE ORGANIZATIONS BEEN WORKING
WITH NGOS ACROSS THE STATE AND
WE'RE VERY EXCITED WHEN THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR PUT
THIS IN PROP.
SIXTY EIGHT AND WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH THE RESOURCES
AGENCY AND THE VARIOUS
DEPARTMENTS ON IMPLEMENTATION.
WE'VE BEEN ADVOCATING FOR THE
FULL 5% TO BE SPENT IN USED
WE'VE ALSO BEEN ADVOCATING FOR
THERE TO BE A STANDALONE PROGRAM
AT EVERY AGENCY.
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK THROUGH
THAT BUT APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION HERE TODAY AND
WOULD LOVE TO CONTINUE WORKING
WITH YOU AND ADMINISTRATION TO
THAT END THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS BATH A LOSS SO ON BEHALF
OF WATER WE USE CALIFORNIA --
HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THE
SEVENTY FOUR MILLION TO THE
STATE BOARD --
FOR WATER RECYCLING.
WE HAVE LONG EXHAUSTED THE PROP
ONE FUNDS --
THERE'S A LARGE LIST OF PROJECTS
READY TO GO --
AND THIS WILL HELP US DIG A
LITTLE BIT INTO THAT SO --
STRONGLY ENCOURAGED KEEPING THAT
MONEY THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS ADAM ROBIN
WITH THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
WATER ASSOCIATION I'D LIKE TO
ASSOCIATE MIKE MARTZ WITH THOSE
FROM THE NATURE CONSERVANCY.
AND ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND
REGARDING THE VOLUNTARY
AGREEMENTS SO MUCH WORK HAS
ALREADY BEEN DONE RELATED TO
THESE AGREEMENTS MORE WORK
REMAINS BUT WE FEEL THAT THE
SEVENTY MILLION DOLLARS ABOUT
PROPOSED ALLOCATION IS
CONSISTENT WITH THE WILL OF THE
VOTERS.
AS EXPRESSED THROUGH PROPOSITION
EIGHT AND REALLY HELPED CATALYZE
THIS PROCESS AS YOU MOVE FORWARD
TOWARDS --
AS THE RECORDS OUTLINED HOPE THE
WRAPPING UP THOSE AGREEMENTS I'M
IN THE COMING YEAR THANK YOU.
SORRY ANALYST I HAVE TO WEAR MY
AUDUBON HAT NOW.
A MISTER OF THEM YOU'RE NOT
COVERED THE THE GROUND WATER
ISSUES BUT ALSO WANT TO RAISE
WITH REGARD TO THE LOWER COST --
COAST ACCOMMODATIONS --
WE KNOW THAT IT WAS CITED IN THE
IN THE BACKGROUND THAT.
THE ISSUE OF THE ASSESSMENT
BEING FINALIZED WAS AT THE CORE
OF WHY IT WAS IN THE JANUARY
PROPOSAL WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
WITH CLOSELY WITH WITH THE
CONSERVANCY NOTE THE IN THE IN
THE ASSESSMENT IS BEING
FINALIZED NOW.
AND WOULD REALLY HATE TO MISS
THE OPPORTUNITY TO GET
APPROPRIATIONS THIS YEAR --
BEGINNING JULY FOR FOR
IMPLEMENTATION OF THAT AND
REALLY CRITICAL PROGRAM --
GIVE AT THAT THANK YOU JUST --
COULD YOU STATE YOUR NAME FOR
THE RECORD BUT OTHER THAN THAT
WE HAVE BOTTOM LINE CALIFORNIA.
GOOD MORNING PAUL MESA PACIFIC
FOREST TRUST I'M GOING TO SAY
EVERYTHING HAS BEEN SAID BUT NOT
EVERYBODY IS SET IT --
I'LL BE VERY BRIEF AND AND I
JUST WANNA HIGHLIGHT THAT
CONCERN TIONS REALLY NEED TO BE
ADDITIVE TO WHAT WE WOULD BE
DOING OTHERWISE AND THE FACT
THAT.
WE HAVE ELIMINATED MOST OF THE
NETWORKING LAND SORT OF
INVESTMENTS FROM THE G. G. R. F. --
APPROPRIATIONS AND OF FILLING
THOSE NEEDS WITH BOND FUNDING TO
VERY EXPENSIVE WAY TO GO ABOUT
MEANING THESE --
FOR ONGOING COSTS SO LET'S
REALLY TRY TO MAKE SURE THEY
WERE USING BOND FUNDS TO MOVE
THE NEEDLE AND NOT JUSTICE
FULFILLED FOR OF BASELINE --
WHAT WILL COME TO EXPECT IS BASS
LINE APPROPRIATIONS THESE
PROGRAMS THANK YOU?
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR ALL OF
YOUR COMMENTS --
IS GARCIA AND MISTER MALL AND
YOU WERE ABSENT WHEN WE HAD OUR
FIRST AND ONLY VOTE TODAY ON THE
VOTE ONLY COUNTY WHICH IS LIKE
THAT ON THAT.
KERN VOTE FOUR ZERO CHAIR VOTING
AYE GARCIA [inaudible]
MULLIN.
THANK YOU SO --
GET A MOVE ON NOW --
TO ITEM NUMBER.
TWO THE ITEMS TO BE HEARD --
IN MY CHOICE IT'S A A REGARDING
DIGITAL MIGRATION.
THE NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY AND
SEVERAL OF OUR DEPARTMENTS ARE
MOVING INTO A NEW BUILDING --
IN.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND AS PART OF
THAT EFFORT TO USE THIS SPACE
MORE EFFICIENTLY --
WE ARE REQUESTING FUNDS TO
DIGITIZE A HUNDRED AND FOUR
MILLIONPAPER PAGES OF RECORDS
SO FOLLOWING ALONG WITH THE
CHAIR WAS TALKING ABOUT EARLIER
USING LESS NATURAL RESOURCES --
THIS EQUATES TO ABOUT A SET 60%
REDUCTION IF YOU INCLUDE ALSO
THE ARCHIVING THAT WE'RE GOING
TO BE DOING.
AND IT'S ABOUT TWENTY FIVE
SQUARE FEET.
OF THE SPACE THAT WE WON'T NEED
IN THE NEW BUILDING FOR STORAGE
SO -- ALONG
WITH DIGITIZING THESE RECORDS
WE'RE GOING TO BE WORKING WITH
THEIR DEPARTMENTS TO MAKE
CHANGES TO THEIR WORK CLOTHES SO
THAT WE DON'T BUILD UP ANOTHER --
BACKLOG OF PAPER PRODUCTS AND
INSTEAD WE WORK TOWARDS USING
DIGITAL METHODS.
THANK YOU LA.
WELL WE DON'T HAVE ANY CONCERNS
WITH THIS PROPOSAL.
THE F..
SO -- HI --
TAKE YOUR WORD ON THE SQUARE
FOOTAGE --
BUT A HUNDRED AND THREE MILLION
700-570-00500 AND TWO PAPER
RECORDS.
HOW DO YOU GET THE KERR?
WE SURVEYED ALL OF OUR
DEPARTMENTS WE WENT ON A NUMBER
OF THINGS.
AROUND THAT IS ALL IT YOU KNOW
IN THE FUTURE IF YOU WANT AROUND
UPPER DEFINITELY WILL THAT WILL
BE OKAY WITH THAT.
THERE TIMES LEGISLATURE REALLY
LIKES EXACT NUMBERS [inaudible]
TOUGH -- THE
ONLY QUESTION I HAVE --
WILL --
UNLESS THERE'S A QUESTION --
THEN LET'S MOVE TO MOTION.
CHECK THAT IS THE FIRST.
GREAT [inaudible]
BLOOM [inaudible]
HI.
FONG GARCIA THANK MULLIN.
SENATE RACE BY.
REQUEST.
EXCELLENT WELL --
LESS PAPER IS A GOOD THING IS I
GOT POINTED OUT BEFORE --
ISSUE NUMBER THREE IS --
THE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE --
FUNDING FOR VARIOUS DEPARTMENTS
SO THIS PROPOSAL REQUESTS --
TO FORTY FIVE MILLION FOR
DEFERRED FIRE. THREE MILLION FOR
EXPOSITION PARK AND ONE MILLION
FOR THE CONSERVATION CORPS.
ON EACH OF THE DEPARTMENTS ARE
PRIORITIZING THE PROJECTS FOR
THESE FUNDS BASED ON THE MOST
IMMEDIATE.
HEALTH AND SAFETY RISKS AND ALSO --
OTHER OPERATIONAL NEEDS.
THANK YOU HI LA --
I THINK OF SOME COMMENTS YES --
AND I WILL NOTE THERE'S AN
ADDITIONAL TWENTY TWO MILLION
FROM PROPOSITION SIXTY EIGHT FOR
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE S WELL AT
DEPARTMENT FISH AND WILDLIFE AND
PARKS SO MY COMMENTS ARE OVER
ARCHING FOR ALL OF THESE.
SIX RESOURCES DEPARTMENTS WE
CERTAINLY THINK MAINTAINING AND
TAKING CARE OF STATE FACILITIES
AND ASSETS IS IMPORTANT BUT WE
HAVE THREE OVER ARCHING COMMENTS
AND CONCERNS ABOUT THIS PROPOSAL.
FIRST IS A LACK OF CLARITY ON
HOW THE SPENDING WILL BE
PRIORITIZED BY EACH DEPARTMENT
SOME OF THE DEPARTMENTS PROVIDED
LISTS FOR EXACTLY HOW THEY WOULD
SPEND THE MONEY AND WHICH
PROJECTS.
AND SOME DID NOT FOR EXAMPLE --
PARKS PROVIDED A TWO HUNDRED
PAGE LIST OF ONE PINT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS OF NEEDS FOR
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE AND SOME
CRITERIA FOR HOW THEY WOULD
PRIORITIZE BUT OBVIOUSLY IT'S
VERY HARD FOR YOU TO UNDERSTAND
EXACTLY HOW.
THEY'RE FORTY FIVE MILLION WILL
BE SPENT WHEN THE NEEDS ARE THAT
GREAT --
SECOND OVERARCHING COMMENT IS
THAT --
PROVIDING DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
MONEY IS REALLY A SHORT TERM
RESPONSE TO AN UNDERLYING
PROBLEM AND SO IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT UNDERSTAND WHAT ARE
THE ONGOING MAINTENANCE NEEDS.
AND RESOURCES AND PRACTICES AT
AND KIND OF AN ONGOING BLEEDING
PROBLEM AND AND THAT THERE ARE
ONGOING MAINTENANCE PRACTICES AT
THESE DEPARTMENTS --
THERE WAS FUNDING EITHER IN THE
CURRENT YEAR ARE PROPOSED FOR
THE BUDGET YEAR FOR THREE OF
THESE SIX DEPARTMENTS --
CONSERVATION CORPS CALIFORNIA
PARKS BUT NOT FOR THE OTHER
THREE AND SO --
WE THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
WHEN USING STATE RESEARCH TO
UNDERSTAND THAT THE UNDERLYING
PROBLEM IS ALSO BEING ADDRESSED.
AND THEN THIRD AT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS NOT PROPOSED A
WAY TO TRACK THE OUTCOMES FOR
THIS FUNDING HOW WILL THEY
ACTUALLY BE SPENT AND HOW WILL
THE LEGISLATURE KNOW THAT FUNDS
WERE SPENT AS PROPOSED.
SO AS NOTED IN YOUR AGENDA WE
PROPOSE --
ADOPTING TWO PIECES OF
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTING LANGUAGE
TO TRY AND GET AT SOME OF THESE
CONCERNS --
REALLY REPORTS THAT DEPARTMENTS
COME BACK AND DESCRIBE HOW THEY
SPENT THE FUNDING SHOULD YOU
CHOOSE TO PROVIDE IT BUT ALSO
WHAT THEIR OVERALL APPROACH IS
ARE IN ADDRESSING THEIR
MAINTENANCE PRACTICES AND
WHETHER THEY'RE ADDRESSING THEIR
BACKLOG OR WHETHER THE BACKLOG
CONTINUES TO GROW TO GET A
HANDLE ON THAT.
UNDERLYING PROBLEM.
THANK YOU THE SAID THE OIL
COMPANY.
GOOD MORNING.
MICHAEL MCGINNIS WITH DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE THE ADMINISTRATION
WOULD BE HAPPY TO PROVIDE.
INFORMATION RELATING TO THE
REQUESTED FUNDS OF THE PROJECTS
THAT THEY WOULD SUPPORT.
HOWEVER AT THE ADMINISTRATION
NOTES THAT DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
FUNDING IS USUALLY A COMPONENT
OF THE DEPARTMENT SPACE BUDGET
AND THAT SUCH REPORTING IS NOT
REQUIRED FOR BASS BUDGET
EXPENDITURES.
SO IN LIEU OF THE HAVE.
PROPOSED AT REPORTING LANGUAGE
WE WOULD SUGGEST INSTEAD THAT
THE INFORMATION BE MADE
AVAILABLE UPON REQUEST BY THE
LEGISLATURE. TO MORE
SPECIFICALLY TARGET SIR.
OKAY SEC THANK YOU --
DOES THE DEPARTMENT WANNA.
RESPOND ANY OF THAT.
I MISS INTO AND TOTAL THE
COMMENTS FROM --
OF THE LA --
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND WE FEEL LIKE THAT
DEPARTMENTS ARE WORKING TOWARDS --
MOST OF APARTMENTS ARE WORKING
TOWARDS AT COMING UP WITH A LIST
OF THE PROJECTS AMONG THE LARGE
BACKLOG AND THEY'LL BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE THAT INFORMATION TO THE
LEGISLATURE.
CRITICS OF THANK YOU --
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS SMITH
PRESS.
ON THE PRIORITIZING TO THE PARKS.
IT SEEMS LIKE A VERY REASONABLE
THING TO TO REQUEST FOR THE ONE
POINT TWO BILLION.
OVER FIVE THOUSAND UNIQUE
PROJECTS.
HOW ARE THE HOW IS THAT GOING TO
BE PRIORITIZE THAT WHEN TO PUT
POINT ONE POINT TWO BILLION?
YEAH SO --
BRAIN DOING --
CONFERENCE IT WORKS.
SO WE HAVE THE FIVE THOUSAND
INDIVIDUAL PROJECTS WE GO
THROUGH A PROJECTS ELECTION TEAM
PROCESS WHEREBY --
THE PROJECTS ARE ARE PRIORITIZED
BASED ON FOR LIFE SAFETY HEALTH
SAFETY SHARED WITH WITH FOLKS.
AND THE THE GROUP GOES THROUGH
THOSE AND SELECTS THE HIGHEST
STATEWIDE PRIORITIES AND EVEN SO --
WE WE COME UP WITH --
NUMBERS OF PROJECTS --
IN A HUNDRED A HUNDRED THOUSAND
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF OF
PROJECTS SO WE WOULD DO IS WE
TAKE THAT LIST OF THE HIGHEST
PRIDE PROJECTS.
AND WE HAVE A RANKING --
PROCESS WHEREBY WE WE RANK IT
BASED ON HEALTH AND SAFETY WE
GIVE --
REVENUE GENERATION --
THIS IS --
NOT YOUR WHOLE AND MAY I ASK.
ONE OF THE ISSUES HAS BEEN ABOUT
CLARITY --
AND DETAILS WHO IS THIS
AVAILABLE CAN IT BE MADE
AVAILABLE TO US.
THE THE LIST OF PROJECTS ONCE WE
HAVE --
IDENTIFIED THAT LIST WE WOULD BE
ABLE -- TO
EXPLAIN WHY THESE LIES PARTY
PROJECTS THAT WERE SELECTED WE
HAVE NOT SELECTED A A LIST OF
PROJECTS AS OF YET --
BY LOOKING AT THE LIST OF
PRODUCTS THAT WE FUNDED OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS --
THEY'RE THEY'RE THEY'RE LARGELY
WATER WASTEWATER.
THOSE THOSE TIMES A PRIVATE WHO
EXPECT THE SAME TYPES OF
PROJECTS TO BE COMING FORWARD.
EVEN AFTER FUNDING THE FOR THE
THE HIGHEST FORTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS WORTH OF PROJECTS WE'RE
STILL GOING TO HAVE --
SO VERY HIGH PARTY PROJECTS THAT
ARE GONNA BE UNFUNDED.
BUT IF WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ONE
POINT. TWO BILLION WITH OVER
FIVE THOUSAND UNIQUE PROJECTS
RIGHT.
THOSE FIVE THOUSAND UNIQUE
PROJECTS.
CAN WE HAVE ACCESS SO THAT WE
CAN SEE WHAT PROJECTS THOSE ARE
YES WE'VE PROVIDED.
A LIST OF THOSE THOSE PROJECTS
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AS
FAR AS AND IN THE FALL BUT ON
BUDGET PROCESS DEVELOPMENT.
THAT HAS BEEN SHARED WITH THE
THE LEGISLATIVE IN A L'OFFICE
AND WE CAN PROVIDE COPIES OF AS
WELL OF THOSE PROJECTS TO YOU.
THANK YOU I I WOULD LIKE THAT
OKAY SO --
PLEASE SHARE THAT INFORMATION
WITH ALL THE MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE.
AND THEN --
MISTER CHAIR ON THE TWO
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM OUR
APPROPRIATE NICE ESPECIALLY IF
AGAIN WE'RE DEALING WITH A LACK
OF CLARITY AYE AYE YOUR POINT IS
WELL TAKEN ABOUT WHAT IS NEEDED
NOT NEEDED.
I THINK THAT --
FOR MYSELF AND I WOULD BE HAPPY
TO MAKE THE MOTION IT WOULD
INCLUDE THOSE TWO REPORTS --
AS RECOMMENDED BY STAFF.
OKAY -- WILL
TAKE THAT AS A MOTION THAT ARE
THERE ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS SO ON THIS --
ISSUE THEN LET'S PROCEED TO A
VOTE.
BLOOM HI FONG GARCIA.
MULLIN PATTERSON RAY YES I
REQUEST.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OUR NECKS.
TO ISSUE IS THE ISSUE --
FOR REGARDING GOT FUND
APPROPRIATIONS AND TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENTS.
SIMILAR TO THE APPROACH LAST
YEAR IN THE EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
BUDGET PROCESS THE AGENCY
COMBINED ALL THE TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENTS SO LIKE RE
APPROPRIATIONS EXTENSION OF
LIQUIDATIONS WERE VERSIONS.
INTO -- ONE
BC P. ALONG WITH SOME OLDER BOND
REQUESTS THERE'S SOME RATED
RESIDUAL BOND FUNDING FROM OLDER
BONDS --
THEN WE DID THAT FOR ONE B. C.
P. IN NINETEEN TWENTY WE HEAR
THAT SIMILAR TO IN PROP SIXTY
EIGHT WE HEAR THE LA THOSE
CONCERNS.
ABOUT NOT HAVING ENOUGH DETAIL
WHEN NEW POSITIONS OR NEW
PROGRAMS ARE PROVIDED AND WE'RE
WILLING TO WE'RE GOING TO BE
WORKING WITH STAFF LIKE WE SAID
EARLIER ON FIGURING OUT WHAT THE
LEVEL OF EACH HAVE A MEETING SET
UP NEXT WEEK FOR THAT.
THANK YOU --
COMMENTS FROM.
YEAH SAME COMMENT MOST OF THESE
ARE OUR TECHNICAL BUT NOT ALL OF
THEM AND SO THEY ARE.
AYE AYE SOME ISSUES HERE WHERE
WE THINK YOU NEED ADDITIONAL
DETAIL HONOR TO UNDERSTAND
WHETHER THEY'RE JUSTIFIED.
LED BY THE ADMINISTRATION'S THAT
OPEN TO THE CONVERSATION THE
PURPOSE FINANCE.
SIR DRAGON OVER THE PART OF
FINANCE JUST TO REITERATE IT WAS
A KIND OF STREAMLINED PROCESS SO
THIS CONSOLIDATION APPROACH WAS
TO TO THAT EFFORT BUT WE DO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE COMMENT FROM
ALLEY ONLY JUST LATER STAFF AND
WE'RE DEFINITELY OPEN TO A
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH YOU
ALL.
TO DEVELOP A FRAMEWORK FOR WHAT
FUTURE ITERATIONS OF THESE
RIPPLES WILL LOOK LIKE.
THANK YOU --
AT CONSISTENT WITH ALL THAT --
WE HAVE A RECOMMENDATION TO HOLD
OPEN TO BE ABLE TO SPEND A
LITTLE MORE TIME WITH THIS ISSUE
WITH ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE WILL HOLD THAT OPEN
MOVE ON TO ISSUE --
FIVE FOR WHICH THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT RADIO REPLACEMENT
[inaudible]
RADIOS THAT.
WE WANT YOU ALL TO BE ABLE TO
TALK TO ANOTHER SITE THE RIVER
PREDICTABLE OUT.
OUTCOME ME.
TOO HI AGAIN MY NAME IS CHUCK
BOND AMONG THE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE.
IN BY WAY OF BACKGROUND FOR THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE MEETING
FOR THE FIRST TIME.
OUR DEPARTMENT IS ONE OF THE
OLDEST DEPARTMENTS IN THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH.
AND OUR JOB IS TO TAKE CARE OF
ALL OF THE STATE'S.
FISH WILDLIFE AND PLANTS ON LAND
AND OUT IN THE OCEAN.
AND WITHIN OUR DEPARTMENT WE
HAVE A LAW ENFORCEMENT DIVISION.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THAT
DIVISION IS COMPRISED OF WARDENS
OR WILDLIFE OFFICERS.
WE ACTUALLY HAVE OUR WILDLIFE
OFFICER FORCE AS HIGH AS IT'S
EVER BEEN IN THE HISTORY OF OUR
DEPARTMENT WE HAVE ABOUT FOUR
HUNDRED AND THIRTY SIX MEMBERS
OF THE DIVISION.
AND I THINK WE AT ANY GIVEN TIME
HAVE OVER THREE HUNDRED AWARDS
IN THE FIELD.
THIS BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSALS
PRETTY SIMPLE.
WE'RE PROPOSING ONE POINT SIX
TWO MILLION DOLLARS OF GENERAL
FUND.
PER YEAR OVER THREE YEARS. TO
REPLACE VEHICLE BASED AND HAND
HELD --
PHONES WHY.
THE RADIOS ARE OUTDATED.
THERE AT THE END OF THEIR USED
IN USEFUL LIFE.
THEY'RE ACTUALLY NO LONGER
AVAILABLE FOR PURCHASE.
AND THE CURRENT ONES DON'T
INTEGRATE WELL INTO THE FEDERAL
FIRST RESPONDER NETWORK
AUTHORITY WHICH IS WHAT ALL
STATE AGENCIES ARE STRIVING TO
DO.
AND ON THIS SIDE OF DESERVE JUST
IN THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS OUR
WILDLIFE OFFICERS HAD BEEN
DEPLOYED.
IN ABOUT TWENTY FIVE OF THE
LARGE WILDLAND FIRES AND NATURAL
DISASTER SINCE TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN SO THIS IS A PRIME
MOTIVATOR FOR US. TO MOVE TO THE
MORE MODERN.
TECHNOLOGICALLY INTEGRATED.
VEHICLE BASED AND HAND HELD
RADIOS THE PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU --
NO CONCERNS WE THINK THAT THIS
MAKES SENSE AND ALSO IT IS AS
THE DIRECTOR NOTED PART OF A
COORDINATED STATEWIDE EFFORT
ACROSS VARIOUS DIFFERENT
AGENCIES TO BE TO ENABLE THEM TO
TALK TO EACH OTHER AS WELL AS
WITH FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR QUESTION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
BLOOM HI FONG GARCIA.
MULLIN.
PATTERSON.
BRASS I REQUEST.
OUR NEXT ISSUE IS NUMBER.
SIX REVOCATION.
AND CONTROL PROGRAM ALL ABOUT --
OUR OUR LEAST FAVORITE RODENT
THIS.
INDEED THESE ARE RODENTS OF
UNUSUAL SIZE.
HOPING TO THAT.
A MOMENT TO MAKE MORE THAN A FEW
PEOPLE SQUIRM.
SO THESE ARE LARGE RODENTS ON
THERE ABOUT THIS BIG.
THEY ARE NATIVE TO SOUTH AMERICA
NOT.
AMERICA --
AND DEFINITELY NOT CALIFORNIA --
THE DEPARTMENT HAD THOUGHT THEY
WERE NO LONGER IN THE STATE
PERHAPS THEY WOULD HAVE BEEN
MIGHT HAVE BEEN HERE IN THE
SIXTIES AND SEVENTIES.
BUT IN SPRING OF TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN WE HAD A REPORT AND
IDENTIFY THE NUTRI AND MERCED
COUNTY.
HERE'S THE PROBLEM --
THE ANIMALS EAT.
LAND AND VEGETATION THEY BURROW
INTO WATER INFRASTRUCTURE THE
BURROW INTO LEVEES THEY COMPETE
WITH NATIVE SPECIES.
THEY ARE AN INVASIVE SPECIES
THAT PRODUCES GREAT RISK FOR THE
STATE.
JUST ON THE WATER SUPPLY FRONT
ALONE.
IMAGINE BURROWING INTO A LEVY
WHICH PROVIDES FLOOD PROTECTION
AND THIS ACTIVITY PROVOKING A
LEVEE COLLAPSED.
SO SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WE HAVE
FOUND ADDITIONAL ANIMALS IN
MERCED IN STANISLAUS COUNTY TO
WOLLEMI COUNTY FRESNO COUNTY SAN
JOAQUIN COUNTY.
AND MARIPOSA COUNTY.
THEY'RE A HOP SKIP AND A JUMP
FROM THE DELTA PROPER.
I HAVE A CHART --
YOU WANT TO PASS AROUND TO YOU
THROUGH THE SERGEANT WHICH
ILLUSTRATES SOME OF THE
POPULATION MODELING WE'VE DONE
JUST ROUGH ESTIMATES.
FROM THE MOMENT OF INDICATION
FIVE YEARS OUT.
IF WE DON'T DO ANYTHING IN FIVE
YEARS WE PROTECT A POPULATION OF
TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY THOUSAND
PLUS.
IN OUR WATERWAYS.
SO THE PROPOSAL TODAY IS. FOUR
ONE POINT. NINE FOUR NINE
MILLION IN GENERAL FUND ONE TIME.
TEN POSITIONS.
AND ONE FOR MILLION ON GOING.
SINCE WE FIRST FOUND THE ANIMALS
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN HERE
ARE THE THINGS THE DEPARTMENT
HAS ALREADY DONE.
WITHIN A YEAR WE COULD WE STOOD
UP AN INCIDENT COMMAND STRUCTURE --
OF EMERGENCY RESPONSE SYSTEM.
WE WE DEDICATED OUR OWN STAFF
OVER FORTY OF THEM FROM EQUALLY
IMPORTANT WORK TO THIS TOPIC.
WE'VE FOUND MATCHING FUNDS WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE.
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES --
THE DELTA CONSERVANCY.
AND WE'VE A RADIC IT'D ABOUT
THREE HUNDRED AND SIXTY THREE
NUTRIA AND WE'VE SURVEYED
970-004-0040 ACRES.
BUT TO AVOID THAT POPULATION
CURVE PROBLEM WE NEED THIS
INVESTMENT NOW --
TO KEEP ON THIS PROBLEM.
HERE ARE TWO EXAMPLES OF WHERE
CALIFORNIA IS AT THIS MOMENT.
NUTRIA WERE FOUND IN THE
CHESAPEAKE BAY.
ON THE EAST COAST.
OVER ABOUT FIFTEEN YEARS --
OF VARIETY OF ENTITIES.
REMOVED ABOUT FOURTEEN THOUSAND
ANIMALS.
AND NOW CONCLUDE.
THE CHESAPEAKE ECOSYSTEM IS
RELATIVELY FREE FROM THE
INVASIVE SPECIES.
COMPARE THAT TO LOUISIANA.
WHEN LOUISIANA HAD THE ANIMAL
APPEAR IT DIDN'T DO MUCH EARLY?
NOW.
YEAR AFTER YEAR IT PAYS TWO
MILLION DOLLARS TO PEOPLE FOR
BOUNTIES.
JUST TO KEEP.
THE POPULATION SUPPRESSED.
NOT REMOVED.
AND IF YOU LOOK AT SOME OF THE
VISUAL AREA AERIAL PHOTOGRAPHS
OF THE LOSS OF WETLANDS IN THE
BY YOU COUNTRY IN LOUISIANA FROM
THE NUTRIA.
IT'S MIND NUMBING.
SO WE WANT TO BE AHEAD OF THIS --
RELATIVE TO THIS INVASIVE
SPECIES THAT'S OUR PROPOSAL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THIS SITE I'M SORRY LET'S GARCIA
DID YOU SAY THAT WE IT WAS THE
SEVENTIES WHEN WE THOUGHT WE
WERE DONE WITH THE NUTRIA YES.
DO WE HAVE ANY IDEA OF WHY NOW
WE DON'T.
BUT SOMEONE BROUGHT THEM
[inaudible]
AS WITH.
I'M ARE YOU COORDINATING WITH
OTHER WESTERN STATES ARE WEST
COAST STATES I'M SO THAT WE'RE
NOT SPENDING MONEY JUST TO HAVE
THEM COME BACK FROM OTHER STATES
YES.
SO OUR PROPOSAL TODAY AND OUR
WORK SINCE SPRING OF TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN HIS MM FORMED
BY A COUPLE STEPS.
WE CALLED UP OUR FEDERAL
COUNTERPARTS WHO ONE OF THE
LEADERS IN THE CHESAPEAKE EFFORT.
WE'VE SPOKEN TO OUR COUNTERPARTS
IN LOUISIANA.
OUR STATE AGENCY IS PART OF A
BROADER ASSOCIATION WHICH IS ALL
OF THE FIFTY WILDLIFE AGENCIES.
WE'VE GONE INTO THAT ASSOCIATION
TO LEARN BEST PRACTICES.
AND WHILE THIS IS CONTROVERSY
ALLIED MEN.
WE'VE ALSO BROUGHT INTO THIS
PROGRAM --
AN ENTITY CALLED WHILE LIKE
SERVICES WHICH IS WITHIN THE
FEDERAL UNITED STATES DEPARTMENT
OF AGRICULTURE.
WHY?
THEY WERE THE MAIN IT TO T.
DOING THE PHYSICAL REMOVAL IN
CHESAPEAKE BAY. ONE WAY TO
IDENTIFY THE AND FIND THE
ANIMALS AS THEIR DOGS TRACKING
THE ANIMALS.
AND WE'VE RELIED ON THEIR
EXPERTISE IN THAT FIFTEEN YEAR
ACT EFFORT IN CHESAPEAKE.
HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
SO WE WENT OUT AND SURVEYED WHAT
PEOPLE HAVE DONE TO INFORM WHAT
WE'RE PROPOSING TO DO.
CAN I TELL YOU TODAY THAT IF WE
DO THIS EFFORT IN THE FUTURE.
WHERE FREE FROM THE REST THAT
SOMEONE MAY BRING NUTRIA BACK
AND NO I CAN'T?
I'LL BUT DO YOU KNOW IF THERE IT --
IF THE ANIMAL IS AN ORGAN OR ANY
OTHER NEIGHBORING STATE --
IT IS NOT IN ARIZONA NEVADA.
I ACTUALLY COULDN'T TELL YOU BUT
I WILL CHECK ABOUT OR AGAIN I
DON'T BELIEVE SO BUT LET ME
CHECK ON THAT.
THANK YOU THAT'S A GREAT
QUESTION I SHOULD KNOW THE
ANSWER.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
AND WE HAVE A RECOMMENDATION TO
APPROVE.
MOTION. TO HEAR SECOND SEC THANK
YOU BLOOM HI FONG GARCIA.
MULLIN.
SEN RAY YES.
REVERSE --
AND THE OF WILL TAKE UP PUBLIC
COMMENT NOW.
GOOD MORNING NO --
KRAMER'S OF THE CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU FEDERATION I WANT TO
APOLOGIZE FOR NOT HAVING A
LETTER INTO THE COMMITTEE ON
THIS BUT I JUST WANTED TO
EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT --
FOR THE DEPARTMENT'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL FOR GEN AND WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT ON
THIS IS IMPORTANT ISSUE TO A
RADIC KATE NUTRIA WE APPRECIATE
THEIR OUTRAGE TO STAKEHOLDERS
AND WORKING.
WITH OTHER AGENCIES TO TO REALLY
FOCUS ON THIS BECAUSE WE WOULD.
HOPE THAT THEY CAN BE SUCCESSFUL
IN A RADICALLY NUTRIA AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE THANK YOU A CAN YOU --
AT JUST --
AND HAVE BEEN OF THE A BRIEF
COUPLE OF SENTENCES --
IDENTIFY --
WHY AG WHAT WHAT WHAT THE --
WHAT THE TREE I CAN DOING GOD --
THE AG IS CONCERNED ABOUT IT SO
OUR CONCERN IS THAT NUTRI BOTH
CONSUME CROPS SO THAT'S OF LOS
TO OUR MEMBERS BUT ALSO.
THE IMPACT THAT THEY HAVE ON
WATER DELIVERY SYSTEMS SO IF WE
HAVE A LEVEE BREAK AS THE
DIRECTOR MENTIONED AND THEN WE
CAN'T. ONE THERE'S DAMAGE --
BUT ALSO THEN IF THAT.
DAMAGES THE IRRIGATION.
SUPPLY DO YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
FOR ME AND ACTUALLY THE FIRST
QUESTION HE SAID WAS NUTRIA WHAT
ARE WE DOING WITH NUTRIA SO IT
IS DEFINITELY A BIG ISSUE --
DOES -- THE
AG INDUSTRY --
HAVE -- US A
SEPARATE FUNDING --
OR PROGRAM TO TRY AND ADDRESS
THE FISH WE DON'T BUT I DO KNOW
THAT I'M ONE OF OUR MEMBERS IS --
SUPPLYING SWEET POTATOES TO USE
AS BATES --
TO HELP ATTRACT THE NUTRI INTO
THE TRAPS --
SO THERE THERE DEFINITELY IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO TO PARTNER
WHERE WE CAN AND PROVIDE
ASSISTANCE WHERE WE CAN.
THANK YOU FOR STATE THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING ROSIE THOMPSON WITH
METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WE ARE IN
AGREEMENT WITH HAVE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION AND WE REQUEST
SUPPORT FOR THE PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU FOR THOUGHT THANK YOU --
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON THANKS --
WE MOVE ON NOW --
TO WHICH BEGINS THE ITEMS FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES ISSUE SEVEN AS THE
CENTRAL VALLEY FLOOD PROTECTION
BOARD --
PERMITTING AND ENFORCEMENT
BRANCH [inaudible]
FUNDING.
GOOD MORNING TERRY BLOOM AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE --
MY NAME IS LESLIE GALLAGHER I'M
THE EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF THE
CENTRAL VALLEY FLOOD PROTECTION
BOARD I THINK THIS IS THE THIRD
YEAR I'VE SEEN YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN SO.
WE'VE BEEN COMING BACK BEFORE
THIS COMMITTEE WITH SUMMER CLASS
SO WE DO HAVE ONE TODAY I WOULD
JUST MENTION --
SINCE WE'RE FOLLOWING UP WITH
THE NEW TREE --
THAT THE COORDINATION AMONG
STATE AGENCIES HAS BEEN REALLY
GREAT ON THAT ISSUE WE ARE IN
ADDITION TO OUR REGULATORY
AUTHORITY WERE ALSO PROPERTY.
WE MANAGE OF A LARGE SWATH OF
PROPERTY AND WE HAVE.
GIVEN.
HUNDREDS OF ENTRY PERMITS FOR
THIS ERADICATION EFFORT AND
WITHOUT COST TO THE STATE
AGENCIES SO WE ARE ALL.
SORT OF WORKING TOGETHER TO MAKE
SURE THEY HAVE ACCESS LEE DU AND
CAUSED DEVASTATION TO LEVEES AND
THAT.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE MANAGE
HERE -- BUT
TODAY I'M TALKING ABOUT --
OUR BUDGET PROPOSAL AND I DO
APPRECIATE THE STAFF QUESTIONS
ABOUT THAT THEY WERE VERY
THOUGHTFUL QUESTIONS AND I KNOW
YOU HAVE SOME DETAILS IN YOUR
STAFF REPORT BUT I JUST WANT TO
GIVE ME ABOUT TWO MINUTES OF
CONTEXT AND THEN RESPOND TO YOUR
QUESTIONS --
THAT WERE SPECIFICALLY PROVIDED --
MISTER BONTA MENTIONED ABOUT --
FISH AND WILDLIFE BEING ONE OF
THE OLDEST AGENCIES THAT YOU
HAVE YOUR ONE OF THE OLDEST
DEPARTMENTS THE BOARD HAS
ACTUALLY BEEN AROUND SINCE
NINETEEN A LAB AND IT WAS THE
RECLAMATION BOARD BEFORE IT WAS.
REIMAGINE DOES THE CENTER VALLEY
FLOOD PROTECTION BOARD AND WE'VE
BEEN OVERSEEING THE STATE PLAN A
FLOOD CONTROL FACILITIES FOR ALL
OF THAT TIME.
SO THIS IS A LITTLE BIT OF A
UNIQUE SITUATION THAT WE HAVE
NOW -- WE
ARE NOT THE PROJECT MANAGER FOR
PROJECTS IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
THAT SOMETHING WE CONTRACT WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES FOR AND THEY PROVIDE
STAFFING AND THEY ALSO OBTAIN
THE BUDGET FOR THOSE PROJECTS.
BUT WE DO MAINTAIN OUR
REGULATORY ROLE THAT THAT IS
THROUGH AT A MEMORANDUM OF
AGREEMENT THAT WE HAVE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT THAT IN OUR
REGULATORY ROLE.
WE MANAGE LOCAL MAINTAINING
AGENCIES THAT PERFORM OPERATIONS
AND MAINTENANCE ON THE
FACILITIES AND WE MANAGE THESE
ENCROACHMENTS THAT ARE IN AND
AROUND THE FACILITIES THE STATE
PLAN OF FLOOD CONTROL.
AND THAT'S THE CRUX OF THIS
REQUEST THAT THE FEDERAL
BIPARTISAN BUDGET ACTIVE TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN CONGRESS
ALLOWED APPROXIMATELY ONE POINT
SIX BILLION DOLLARS TO THE ARMY
CORPS OF ENGINEERS TO BE SPENT
ON THIS PROJECT IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY IN BY THIS PROJECT I MEAN
WHAT WE'RE CALLING THE AMERICAN.
RIVER COMMON FEATURES IT'S A
VERY IMPORTANT PROJECT IT'S
SOMETHING THAT'S BEEN ON OUR
RADAR FOR A LONG TIME THAT NEEDS
IMPROVEMENT AND THE STATE AND
THE LOCAL ENTITIES.
HAVE ALL --
ALREADY GOTTEN THEIR SHARE OF
FUNDING FOR THAT WHAT THIS
INFUSION OF FEDERAL FUNDING DID
THOUGH IS PROVIDE US WITH THIS.
ABOUT EIGHTEEN TIMES WHAT THEY
WOULD NORMALLY GET IN A YEAR AND
THAT CAUSED THAT THE ARMY CORPS
TO GO INTO.
HI DEAR AND ON THE STATE SIDE WE
WANTED TO CLEAR THE DECKS OF ANY --
THING THAT MIGHT BE IN THE WAY
OF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT BEING
ABLE TO SPEND WITH THIS LARGE
ASK BECAUSE THIS IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT HAPPENS IN.
THIRTY YEARS THIS IS NEVER
HAPPENED SO WE WANTED TO BE ABLE
WE CAN TO MAKE SURE WE COULD
LEVERAGE ALL THAT MONEY.
MORE RECENTLY AND THIS IS THE
CRUX OF THE QUESTIONS THERE'S
BEEN SOME SPECULATION THAT THE
PRESIDENT'S EMERGENCY
DECLARATION WILL INTERFERE OR RE
DIRECT THE FUNDING THAT HAS BEEN.
IDENTIFIED FOR THIS PROJECT IN
AND SPECIFICALLY WHAT WOULD
HAPPEN.
TO OBJECTS THAT THE FEDERAL
FUNDING DIDN'T MATERIALIZE.
I'M.
I I CAN'T SPECULATE WITH
SPECULATE ON WHAT MIGHT HAPPEN --
BUT I DO KNOW THAT THE STATE AND
THE ARMY CORPS IF TAKEN --
SIGNIFICANT STEPS TO PROTECT
THIS FUNDING WE'VE ALREADY
SIGNED THAT PROJECT PARTNERSHIP
AGREEMENT WHICH ACCORDING TO THE
ARMY CORPS PUTS THIS IN A POT OF
MONEY THAT'S ALREADY COMMITTED
AND AND THEREFORE.
MAYBE IN A DIFFERENT SPOT NOT
DONE EVERYTHING THAT WE COULD TO
ENSURE THAT WE ARE IN.
A PROCESS FOR MOVING FORWARD.
AND EVEN IF THIS FUND THIS
FEDERAL FUNDING WERE TO BE RE
DIRECTED THIS PROJECT WOULD
STILL GO FORWARD IT WOULD JUST
GO FOR IT AT AT AT A SLOWER PACE
THAN THIS BREAKNECK SPEED THAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT NOW --
IT IS POSSIBLE IF THAT WERE TO
HAPPEN THAT THESE FINDINGS MAY
GO ARE THESE POSITIONS MAY GO ON
FUNDED AROUND FILLED FOR A
PERIOD OF TIME --
BUT I THINK THE GREATER RISK
HERE IS IF WE ARE NOT PREPARED
AT AND THIS PROJECT DOES MOVE
FORWARD AND WE ARE NOT ABLE TO
DEAL WITH THE ENCOURAGEMENT
THAT'S REALLY THE GREATER RISK
HERE AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE HERE
WITH THIS REQUEST. FOR
REIMBURSABLE FUNDING FIVE
POSITIONS TO THE BOARD TO MANAGE
OUR REGULATORY AUTHORITY --
ON REMOVING ENCROACHMENTS AHEAD
OF THE SACRAMENTO RIVER EAST
LEVY PROJECT AND THAT IS
SCHEDULED TO START OUT EARLY
NEXT YEAR --
THE SACRAMENTO FLOOD CONTROL
AGENCY BOARD HAS ALREADY AGREED
TO THE FUNDING THAT'S BEEN
OUTLINED IN THIS BUDGET REQUEST
AND WE ARE REQUESTING THAT THE
COMMITTEE FOLLOW STAFF
RECOMMENDATION AND APPROVED THAT
THIS BUDGET AND WITH THAT I
WOULD JUST TAKE ANY OTHER
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME.
WE HAVE A RECOMMENDATION TO
APPROVE THIS ITEM IS BUDGET IF
[inaudible]
THEIR MOTION --
I FORGOT TO ASK A LA OVER YEAH
NO CONCERNS WE THINK THIS IS A
GOOD EXAMPLE OF BENEFICIARY PAYS
PRIVATE COMPANIES PARTNERSHIP
NEXT TIME I MISSED THAT JUST YOU
KNOW.
TAKE A WHAT A PAPER FOR MY DRESS.
TO HAVE A MOTION AND SECOND AND
TO WILL MOVE TO VOTE.
BLOOM HI FONG GARCIA MULLIN --
SENT.
RAY YES I REQUEST.
GREAT SAID THANK YOU I THINK I
MISS YOU A IS THE CONTINUATION
OF CALIFORNIA STATEWIDE
GROUNDWATER ELEVATION MONITORING.
GOOD MORNING CARL IN A METHOD
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES OF BEFORE YOU WE
HAVE A PROPOSAL FOR TWO POINT
TWO MILLION --
IN FISCAL YEAR NINETEEN TWENTY
AND TWO MILLION THERE AFTER FOR
MAINTENANCE OF WELL ELEVATION
AND WELL DRILLING DATA.
THIS CHASM SYSTEM IS USED BY MY
MEET MANDATED GROUNDWATER
ELEVATION REPORTING REQUIREMENTS.
THE FUNDING WILL ALSO SUPPORT --
THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES STAFF TO PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO THOSE
ENTITIES AND GROUNDWATER
SUSTAINABILITY AGENCIES AS THEY
MODIFY CAST JIM INFORMATION AND
MONITORING PLANS. TO ACCOMMODATE --
THE SUSTAINABLE GROUND WATER
MANAGEMENT ACT RELATED
REQUIREMENTS.
THE FUNDING ALSO SUPPORTS OUR
EFFORTS TO CONTINUE TO IMPLEMENT
AND ENHANCE ONLINE WELL --
COMPLETION REPORTING SYSTEM
WHICH SUPPORTS GROUND WATER
MANAGEMENT EFFORTS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE --
AS YOU KNOW A PART OF OUR
CHALLENGE IN THE SUSTAINABLE
GROUND WATER MANAGEMENT --
ACT IMPLEMENTATION IS WE HAVE
BEEN PERFECT INFORMATION --
AND AS WE ARE ASKING FOLKS TO
PUT TOGETHER THEIR PLANS WE ARE
ALSO SUPPORTING.
NOT ONLY THEIR CONSOLIDATION OF
DATA BUT THEIR ON GOING UPDATING
OF THAT DATA BECAUSE WE WILL
ONLY BE AS GOOD AS THE
INFORMATION THAT WE HAVE THAT
HELPS US MAKE THOSE DECISIONS.
BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE.
THANK YOU LA OVER.
IMPORTANT COMPREHENSIVE
INFORMATION THE STATE NEEDS IN
ORDER TO MONITOR ITS GROUNDWATER
RESOURCES BOTH FOR THOSE BASINS
COVERED BY SIGMA BUT IMPORTANTLY
THIS WOULD ALSO COVER SOME OF
THE LOWER PRIORITY BASINS THAT
ARE NOT CURRENTLY COVERED BY
SIGMA AND BRING THEM IN.
TO ABOUT THE STATEWIDE DATA
COLLECTION SO WE'D RECOMMEND
APPROVAL.
THANK YOU QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
THE SERVER IS OUR MOTION
RESPECTING.
AND EFFECTIVE.
THE SECOND.
THANK YOU BLOOM HI FONG
[inaudible]
GARCIA [inaudible] ONE PATTERSON.
YES I REQUEST.
THANK YOU --
ISSUE NINE IS THE PARENTS DAM
REMEDIATION PLAN.
OKAY AS YOU MAY BE AWARE PARRIS
DAM AND RESERVOIR ARE LOCATED IN
SAN BERNADINO COUNTY.
AND THEY SERVICE THE TERMINAL
RESERVOIR FOR THE STATE WATER
PROJECT.
THE LAKE PARRIS OF STATE
RECREATION AREA IS ALSO A HIGHLY
POPULAR AND VISITED RECREATIONAL
FACILITY AND HAS A MORE THAN ONE
MILLION VISITORS ANNUALLY.
AND THE FACILITY PROVIDES
BOATING SWIMMING AND OTHER WATER
BASED RECREATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES.
IN TWO THOUSAND FIVE THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES
IDENTIFIED POTENTIAL SEISMIC
SAFETY RISKS.
IN A SECTION OF THE FOUNDATION
OF PARIS DAY SAME YEAR WE MOVED
AHEAD WITH EARLY PHASES OF THE
REPAIR OF THE TOTAL COST OF THE
PROJECT HAS BEEN ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTY SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS.
THIS SEISMIC RETROFITTING
RECONSTRUCTION OF THE DAM ITSELF
WAS COMPLETED IN MARCH OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND IT CORRECTED THE
SOIL TYPE CONCERNS WITH
FOUNDATION.
IT'S STABILIZE THE DOWNSTREAM
FACE OF THE DAM AND INSTALLED AS
A SYSTEM OF RELIEF WELLS TO
ADDRESS SEEPAGE AND OTHER
ANCILLARY IMPROVEMENTS. TO
PROJECT ELEMENTS STILL REMAIN
THE PARRIS DAM OUTLET TOWER
IMPROVEMENTS PROJECT AND THE
PARRIS DAM EMERGENCY RELEASE
FACILITY PROJECT.
THESE TWO PROJECTS WILL FURTHER
ADDRESS SEISMIC ISSUES RELATED
TO THE RESERVOIRS ABILITY TO
MAKE RELEASES WITHOUT CONTEXT
WHAT WE HAVE BEFORE YOU IS A A
FUNDING REQUEST FROM PROPOSITION
EIGHTY FOUR WHICH INCLUDED FIFTY
TWO MILLION SPECIFICALLY FOR
RECREATION.
AND FISH AND WILDLIFE
ENHANCEMENT COST OF STATE WATER
PROJECT FACILITIES.
THIS PARTICULAR PROPOSAL OF FOR
PARIS DAM REQUESTS FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS OF THOSE FUNDS IN
SUPPORT OF THE BENEFITS OF THE
OVERALL SEISMIC REMEDIATION
PROJECTS --
THAT THEY PROVIDE TO THE
RECREATION AND FISHING WILDLIFE
ENHANCEMENT COMPONENTS OF THE
STATE WATER PROJECT.
THESE DOLLARS ARE RESTRICTED FOR
THE TYPE OF USE PROPOSED HERE
AND ARE CONSISTENT WITH PAST
LEGISLATIVE ACTION.
RELATING TO RECREATION AND OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE ENHANCEMENT.
THANK YOU HELLO YEAH YOU SO YOU
USUALLY WITH FOR A STATE WATER
PROJECT THE USERS OF THE WATER
PAY FOR MOST OF THE FACILITIES
AND AM BUT THERE IS.
AS THE DIRECTOR MENTIONED WHEN
THERE'S A RECREATIONAL OR FISH
AND WILDLIFE ANGLE TO IT THEN
THERE'S A STATE COSTS CHAIR SO
THE PROPOSAL HERE IS CONSISTENT
WITH THE STATE COST SHARE ABOUT
32% STATE. 68% WATER CONTRACTORS
ACTIVITIES AT THIS FACILITY SO
BECAUSE THAT CONSISTENTLY WE
DON'T HAVE ANY CONCERNS.
GREAT THANK YOU FINANCE --
ANY MOVE COMMENTS.
I EXPECTED MEN'S RESTROOM.
MAKE THE MOTION GIVEN THE
PROXIMITY OF THE DAM TO FOR
COUNTY --
THANK YOU.
BLOOM.
HI FONG GARCIA MULLIN PATTERSON
RAY YES I REQUEST.
ED WILL MOVE ON NOW TO ISSUE --
TEN REGARDING SYSTEM WIDE FLOOD
IMPROVEMENT PROJECTS MISTER
CHAIR I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE --
CHRIS TURN NOW HE'S THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR MULTI BENEFIT
INITIATIVES AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES AND HE WILL GIVE
AN OVERVIEW OF THIS ISSUE THAT'S
QUITE A TITLE.
WELCOME TO STEP.
THREE THANK YOU VERY MUCH GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE IS A PLEASURE TO
BE HERE AGAIN CHRIS TURN OUT TO
BE DIRECTOR AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES HAVE FIT ON YOUR
BUSINESS CARD.
IT'S THIS BIG --
SO AGAIN IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE
HERE ESPECIALLY TALK ABOUT THIS
PARTICULAR SUBJECT --
IT'S A IT'S A IT'S A SUBJECT FOR
SPLIT PROTECTIONS WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HERE --
CERTAINLY APPROPRIATE FOR TODAY
IT IS RAINING OUTSIDE --
OUR SYSTEM IS FULL AND WHAT
WE'RE REALLY SEEING ESPECIALLY
IF YOU DRIVE BETWEEN HERE AND
DAVIS OR IF YOU HAPPEN TO FLY
INTO TOWN ON YOUR COMMUTE TO
SACRAMENTO.
LOOK AT YOUR YOUR WINDOW IF
YOU'RE SO SO HERE IN DAVIS IS --
A YELLOW BYPASS A FLOOD CONTROL
FACILITY AUTHORIZED BY CONGRESS
A HUNDRED YEARS AGO.
IT IS FULL OF WATER IT IS DOING
WHAT IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE DOING
IS AN ELEGANT PASSIVE A FLOOD
MANAGEMENT --
FACILITY AND IT IS --
AN EXAMPLE OF WHAT WE SEE FOR
FLOOD MANAGEMENT UP AND DOWN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY THAT PROTECTS
URBAN AREAS ACROSS THE THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AGRICULTURAL
AREAS SMALL COMMUNITIES AND
OTHERS.
AND AND WHAT WE ARE THINKING
ABOUT WE THINK ABOUT ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENTS IN THESE TYPES OF
RESOURCES.
LOOKING AT WHERE IS THEIR
EXISTING NEED SOMEWHERE TO THE
FACILITIES CURRENTLY --
DEFICIENT TO OUR STANDARDS AND
TO FEDERAL STANDARDS --
AND ALSO WHERE ARE WE GOING TO
NEED THOSE INVESTMENTS TO DEAL
WITH A CHANGING CLIMATE SO
SEALEVEL RISE I CHANGED INLAND
HYDROLOGY THINGS ALONG THOSE
LINES.
AND FROM THERE LEGISLATURE AND
THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
VOTERS OF ON CALIFORNIA
RECOGNIZED THIS NEED WHEN THEY
PASSED PROPOSITION ONE
PROPOSITION --
SIXTY EIGHT BUT THE SIGNIFICANT
FLOOD FINANCING IN EACH OF THOSE
THOSE THOSE MEASURES AND WHAT
THEY ALSO RECOGNIZE THERE'S A
TREMENDOUS LINK ESPECIALLY THE
CENTRAL VALLEY BETWEEN FLOOD
PROTECTION.
AND SPECIES RESTORATIONS OF
FISHERIES RESTORATION SO WHAT
THE PROPOSAL IS BEFORE YOU HERE
TODAY AND IF I MAY --
ACTUALLY MY COMMENTS ARE
COMBINED THE NEXT.
TO I'M ITEMS BOTH TEN AND ELEVEN
I BELIEVE --
SYSTEM WIDE QUOTE UNQUOTE AND
URBAN FLOOD MEN'S BOTH LARGE AND
SMALL WITH A. BE IN THE LEAD IN
THE PLEDGE BYPASS SYSTEM LIKE
THE YOLO BYPASS AGAIN BETWEEN
HERE AND DAVIS YOU DRIVE OVER --
OR SMALLER PROJECTS LIKE THE
BUTTE SLOUGH ALL OUT FALL GATES
IN BOTH CASES THESE PROJECTS AS
IDENTIFIED IN LISTED IN YOUR
AGENDA ADDRESS WELL KNOWN AND
SUSPICION DEFICIENCIES TO THE
FLOOD SYSTEM.
THAT WHEN IMPROVE WILL INCREASE
PROTECTIONS --
TO COMMUNITIES --
AND ALSO WILL HELP IMPROVE THE
CONDITIONS FOR FISH AND WILDLIFE
ACROSS THE SYSTEM THAT'S A
REQUIREMENT OF THE BOND WE'VE
IDENTIFIED PROJECTS WHERE.
WE'RE READY TO MOVE ON EFFORTS
TO ACHIEVE BOTH OF THOSE
OBJECTIVES AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH YOU AND
COMMUNITIES ON THOSE PROJECTS AS
THEY COME TO FRUITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
OF IS THERE AND OF THAT OFFER
SALAS GALILEO AND DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND THEN --
TO SWITCH SORT OF COMBINED ITEMS --
OF JUST ASK IF THERE'S COMMENTS
ON BOTH OF THEM.
YEAH I'VE DONE IT FOR SO FOR TEN
AND ELEVEN I THINK THE PROJECTS
THAT ARE PROPOSED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION ARE CONSISTENT
WITH THE BOND LANGUAGE AND WE
WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING TO
SCHEDULE OUT THE PROJECTS AND
AMOUNTS IN THE BUDGET ACT SO
THAT IF THEY ARE.
CHANGES DURING THE YEAR THEY
WILL HAVE TO BE RIVER BACK TO
YOU THROUGH THE GBC WHICH IS
SOMETHING THAT THE LEGISLATURE
HAS A QUESTION PRIOR YEARS AND
THIS YEAR THE ADMINISTRATIONS
PUT FORTH SO HAPPY TO SEE THEM.
THANK YOU FINANCE --
OKAY SO --
IS THERE ANY --
COMMENT --
OR QUESTIONS ON ISSUES TEN OR
ELEVEN IF NOT THEN --
I'LL ENTERTAIN A MOTION SIGN A
SINGULAR MOTION FOR BOTH ISSUES
TEN ANALYSTS.
BLOOM I FONG GARCIA MULLIN.
SEN RAY YES I REQUEST.
THANK YOU --
AND THAT WILL TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THAT ALL OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES
ISSUES.
THE GOOD GOOD MORNING ROBERT COR
FROM THE GLOBAL FUND BEHALF OF
SAFECO WHICH IS IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF TEN AND ELEVEN AND
ASSOCIATES OURSELVES WITH THE
PRIOR.
UGH -- ISSUE
AS NUMBER SEVEN SAFE IS NOW THE
NATION'S NUMBER ONE AT RISK OF
FLOOD TO CONTROL IT --
AREA MANAGER WE WERE LOCATION
AND OF A SICK TO CONTINUE
FEDERAL FUNDING --
AS WE HAVE FOR DECADES AND
APPRECIATE THE DEPARTMENT
SUPPORT AND WE WILL PUT A LETTER
IN THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI ROBIN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
WATER ASSOCIATION REGARDING
ISSUE TEN WE REALLY APPRECIATE
THE DEPARTMENT'S WORK ON THIS
ISSUE AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
STAFF RECOMMENDATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OUR LAST
ISSUE OF THE DAY --
UNDER A COMBINED DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES AND STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD.
ON THIS ISSUE --
TWELVE REGARDING THAT MAKING
WATER CONSERVATION CALIFORNIA
WAY OF LIFE PROGRAM --
MAYBE I'LL TURN IT TO MS EILEEN
SO BACK TO INTRODUCE HERSELF.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS EILEEN SO BACK I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR.
OF THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD OF MY NEWLY
APPOINTED --
CHAIR OF THE BOARD JOAQUIN ASK
OF ALL SENSES --
APOLOGIES --
BUT HE IS CHAIRING HIS FIRST --
WATER BOARD MEETING --
TODAY OR DAY TWO OF HIS FIRST
WATER BOARD MEETING BUT HE LOOKS
FORWARD TO APPEARING ON VERY
SOON BEFORE THE CREDIT GRAY WILL
A KIND OF A LITTLE SLACK.
TODAY.
IN ADDITION TO HIS LONG TITLE ON
MULTI BENEFIT PROJECTS A DEPUTY
DIRECTOR TURN NOW ALSO MANAGES
OUR OUR WATER USE EFFICIENCY AND
INTEGRATED REGIONAL WATER
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM.
HELP MAKE SOME OVER ARCHING
COMMENTS AND THEN TURN IT OVER
TO THE TECHNICAL STAFF --
AND AND OF COURSE OF WATER
POURED REPRESENT AND
REPRESENTATIVES HERE AND AS
MIGHT BE THE WILL OF THE
COMMITTEE.
SO I THINK THAT THE THE TITLE OF
THIS AGENDA ITEM IS --
IS APT AND IT'S CONSISTENT WITH
THE DIRECTION THIS
ADMINISTRATION --
FOR CERTAINLY SPANNING THE BROWN
ADMINISTRATION CREATION AND THAT
IS THIS QUESTION OF HOW TO MAKE
WATER CONSERVATION A WAY OF LIFE.
IN SOME WAYS THAT COULD BE SEEN
AS KIND OF A OF A SIMPLE BUMPER
STICKER TYPE STATEMENT IT'S ALSO
I THINK.
REALLY INDICATIVE OF A BURIAL
ULTIMATELY TRYING TO DO HERE
WHICH IS MAKE REAL CULTURAL
CHANGE IN CALIFORNIA.
I'M NOT JUST --
INVESTING PIECEMEAL IN WATER USE
EFFICIENCY NOT JUST DOING THINGS
AS ONE OFF APPROACHES BUT REALLY
GETTING TO THE CORE QUESTION OF
HOW DO WE START CHANGING THE
CULTURAL DYNAMIC.
IN THE STATE SO THAT WATER USE
EFFICIENCY COMES PART AND PARCEL
TO FOUNDATIONAL --
TO REALLY A BUILDING BLOCK OF A
STRONG WATER SUPPLY --
PORTFOLIO ACROSS THE STATE FOR
ALL COMMUNITIES.
AND SO THIS COMMUNITIES BEEN OR
THIS COMMITTEE RATHER'S BEEN
INVOLVED IN A LOT OF THAT WORK
TO DATE.
THINGS LIKE --
PASSING BUDGET MATTERS WITH
LOCAL ASSISTANCE FINANCING THAT
THE DEPARTMENT AND THE WATER
BOARD USE FOR DIRECT ASSISTANCE
TO LOCAL COMMUNITIES FOR
IMPROVEMENTS AND MARK
SUFFICIENCY.
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AGAIN
WORKING WITH YOUR COMMITTEE IN
THE LEGISLATURE TO EMPOWER US TO
WORK REALLY CLOSELY WITH
COMMUNITIES ON THE GROUND TO
WORK THROUGH SOME OF THE REALLY
TRICKY --
TECHNICAL ISSUES RELATED TO
WATER USE EFFICIENCY IN THAT OF
COURSE GOES FOR THE ON BOARD AS
WELL I CAN BE SO BOLD AS TO SAY
THAT.
AND THIRDLY AND PUBLIC EDUCATION --
THERE IS THE THE THE THAT THIS
COMMITTEE FUNDED --
WITH SEVERAL MILLION DOLLARS
LAST CYCLE I BELIEVE LAST YEAR
AROUND BEFORE THAT THE REALLY
AGAIN GETS AT THIS PUBLIC
EDUCATION SIDE OF MAKING WATER
USE --
EFFICIENCY A CALIFORNIA WAY OF
LIFE WATER CONSERVATION THE
CALIFORNIA WAY OF LIFE.
AND THERE'S THIS FOURTH
COMPONENT AND THAT'S WHAT I FEEL
LIKE WE ARE REALLY HERE TODAY TO
TALK ABOUT AND THAT IS.
WHAT ARE THE WHAT IF THE WATER
USE EFFICIENCY AND THE
PROGRESSIVE WATER USE EFFICIENCY
REQUIREMENTS THAT WE LOOK TO OUR
LOCAL WATER AGENCIES TO HELP US
IMPLEMENT SO BE ON PUBLIC
EDUCATION BEYOND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE BEYOND LOCAL
ASSISTANCE THAT WE CAN PROVIDE?
WHAT IS THAT BECAUSE I
REGULATORY IF YOU WILL
REQUIREMENTS THAT MAKES SENSE
FOR US TO CONTINUE TO PUSH THE
NEEDLE I WORRY SUFFICIENCY?
AND HOW TO THOSE FOUR PIECES FIT
TOGETHER --
THE LEGISLATURE A PAST IN THE
GOVERNOR SIGNED LAST YEAR TWO
PIECES OF LEGISLATION SB SIX OH
SIX HERTZBERG AN A. B. SIXTEEN
SIXTY EIGHT FRIEDMAN.
BUT AGAIN REALLY GETS THIS
FOURTH ASPECT --
IN MY VIEW OF WHAT THE
SUFFICIENCY AND THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE HERE TALKING ABOUT TODAY
AND I WILL GIVE MY COMMENTS AT
THAT BUT ESSENTIALLY WHAT YOU
HAVE IN FRONT OF YOU.
IS -- A
MODEST BUT SIGNIFICANT PROPOSAL
FROM BOTH STATE AID AGENCIES I'M
WHO IN WORKING EXTREMELY CLOSE
TOGETHER --
BEEN VERY CLOSE PARTNERSHIP ON
IMPLEMENTATION OF THOSE PIECES
OF LEGISLATION TO A MOVE THAT
NEEDLE AND LASTING ALSO BEFORE I
PASS IT OFF --
IS THAT I HAVE HERE --
FIND A WAY OF LIFE THE PRIMER --
OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN LEGISLATION
ON WATER CONSERVATION AND THIS
IS REALLY A DOCUMENT CREATED FOR
OURSELVES FOR YOU AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY FOR THE PUBLIC. TO
SEE EXACTLY HOW THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD THE
DEPARTMENT WATER RESOURCES OTHER
STATE AGENCIES WE WORKING
TOGETHER WITH OUR PUBLIC AND AND
PRIVATE PARTNERS. TO IMPLEMENT
THIS LEGISLATION SO LEAVE THOSE
HERE WITH YOU AND IT REALLY DOES
LAY OUT A ROADMAP FOR HOW WE
PLAN TO IMPLEMENT THIS
LEGISLATION AND THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL IN FRONT OF YOU.
HELP MAKE THAT HAPPEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. TO CARE THAT.
WE DO WE HAVE WE DO HAVE
TECHNICAL --
FOLKS TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE [inaudible]
WITH WITH.
OUR THIRTY DEPARTMENTS OR
AGENCIES THAT ARTICULATING ANY
ISSUES WITH IMPLEMENTING --
MEETING THE GOALS OF SB --
SIX SIX DAVEY.
SIXTEEN SIXTY EIGHT HOW DOES HOW
DOES THE DEPARTMENT PROPOSED TO
ASSIST IN THIS TRANSITION.
SO I'LL PASS IT OFF TO TO
PETERBOROUGH STRAM --
WHO STANDING BEHIND ME HERE TO
ANSWER SOME OF THESE QUESTIONS
IT'S MY GENERAL UNDERSTANDING
BEFORE I PASS IT OFF OF THAT?
GIVEN WHERE WE ARE AT WITH THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS
LEGISLATION --
THAT WE ARE NOT HEARING SPECIFIC
CONCERNS --
FROM OUR LOCAL AGENCY PARTNERS
THAT GETS TO THE HEART OF THIS --
BUDGET PROPOSAL TO MAKE SURE
THAT AS IMITATION REALLY GEARS
UP THAT WE ARE FULLY STAFFED AND
ABLE TO ANSWER AND ADDRESS THOSE
ISSUES.
AND IF AND IF I MIGHT ADD FROM
THE STATE WATER PORTS
PERSPECTIVE YOU KNOW WE REALLY
WE HAVE WE HAVE A LOT OF
EXPERIENCE WITH BOTH --
EMERGENCY MEASURES DURING THE
DROUGHT AND THEN WHAT ARE NOW
BALLING SOME VOLUNTARY REPORTING
MEASURE SO WE HAVE A LOT OF
LESSONS LEARNED AND FOR WE
REALLY WANT TO INCORPORATE THOSE
GOING FORWARD.
AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE A VERY INCLUSIVE ROBUST.
STAKEHOLDER --
PROCESS SO AT SO THAT IT IS --
AS A USER FRIENDLY AS IT AS IT
CAN BE BUT WE ARE REALLY AT THE
FRONT END OF THAT PROCESS RIGHT
NOW AND WHAT WE ARE ASKING FOR
IN THIS --
IN THIS IN THIS PACKAGE THE
SPIRIT JOINT WELL COORDINATED
PACKAGE IS THE RESOURCES TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE DO THAT.
PETER BRISTER MIGHT LEAD THE
WATER USE EFFICIENCY BRANCH --
AT THE W. R. I. AND AS HAS BEEN
SAID WE ARE JUST NOW STARTING
IMPLEMENTING THE PROGRAM.
SOME OF THE FIRST PROGRAMS
CRITICAL PART OF IT IS THE
LANDSCAPE AREA MEASUREMENT --
WE HAD A TECHNICAL WORK GROUP
LAST WEEK WHERE WE WENT OVER
ISSUES --
YOU KNOW THERE ARE A FEW
OBSTACLE.
A WE DON'T SEE THAT CAN BE
OVERCOME AND WORK THROUGH IT'S A
BIG PROJECT.
WE ARE DEVELOP IN LANDSCAPE AREA
MEASUREMENTS FOR FOUR HUNDRED
WATER SUPPLIERS.
ACROSS THE STATE NINE MILLION
PARCELS --
BUT WE FEEL WE'RE OFF TO A VERY
GOOD START ON IT.
I JUST TOOK THE THIRD IF THERE
ARE ISSUES THAT YOU BRING.
BRING IT TO THE APPROPRIATE
[inaudible]
THE COMMITTEE TO MAKE SURE
THEY'RE DRESSED SO THAT WE CAN
IMPLEMENT EXACTLY WHAT WAS
OVERCAST [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HELLO DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
YES THANK YOU WE RECOMMEND
APPROVAL OF THIS APP PROPOSAL WE
THINK IT'S CONSISTENT WITH THE
LEGISLATION THAT WAS PASSED BUT
AS IS MENTIONED THIS IS REALLY
JUST THE FIRST STEP.
IMPLEMENTING THE DEPARTMENTS
WILL GO THROUGH AND ESTABLISHING
THE STANDARDS ESTABLISHING THE
TEMPLE IT'S ESTABLISHING THE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND THEN IN
SUBSEQUENT YEARS IT'S GOING TO
BE UP TO THE LOCAL AGENCIES TO
COMPLY.
SO ON PAGE FORTY AND FORTY ONE
WHAT WHAT WE HAVE HIGHLIGHTED IS
OF YOUR AGENDA WHAT WE HAVE
HIGHLIGHTED ARE SOME KEY
OVERSIGHT QUESTIONS THAT WE
THINK WILL BE IMPORTANT TO
CONTINUE ASKING.
NOT JUST TODAY BUT IN THE COMING
MONTHS AND YEARS BOTH HOW IS
THIS PROGRESS SAYING ARE WE
HITTING OUR DEADLINES WHAT WE
HEARING FROM LOCAL AGENCIES BUT
ULTIMATELY ARE WE MEETING THE
GOALS ARE WE MEETING THE
OUTCOMES OF THIS LEGISLATION --
WAS SET UP. TO TO ACHIEVE FOR
OUR STATE SO I'M REALLY AT THE
FIRST STAGE BUT THESE TYPES OF
QUESTIONS WE THINK ARE THE KINDS
OF THINGS THAT CAN BE IMPORTANT
TO ASK AS THE YEARS PROGRESSED
[inaudible]
FINANCE --
WILL ASK FOR PUBLIC COMMENT NOW
IN THIS --
ITEM THAT IS SO HAS A
RECOMMENDATION FOR APPROVED AS
BUDGET [inaudible]
THANKS --
ROBERT CORRIGAN FROM THE GOLF A
GROUP ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
FRESNO MODESTO IRRIGATION KERN
COUNTY WATER.
KINGS RIVER CONSERVATION THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF WINE
GRAPE GROWERS WEREN'T STRONG
SUPPORTER THIS IN PARTICULAR THE
FUNDING SOURCE THANK YOU --
MY NAME IS TRACY QUINN WITH AN
RTC AT IN SUPPORT OF THIS BUDGET
PROPOSAL I WAS A MEMBER OF THE
URBAN ADVISORY GROUP THAT HELPED
YOU INFORM AND DEVELOP THE
FRAMEWORK THE MAKING WATER
CONSERVATION A CALIFORNIA WITH
LIKE FRAMEWORK THAT LED TO THE
LEGISLATION.
AND WORK CLOSELY CLOSELY WITH
BOTH AUTHORS OFFICES THIS IS
TRULY TRANSFORMATIONAL AND HOW
WE'RE GOING TO MANAGE OUR WATER
GOING FORWARD.
AND THE STATE AGENCIES OUT
REALLY APPROPRIATELY SO --
I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
THAT WAS PROMOTION.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
BLOOM HI.
FONG GARCIA MULLIN.
PATTERSON RAY YES [inaudible]
REQUEST.
THAT BRINGS US TO THE CONCLUSION
OF FOR THE CONCLUSION OF THE YES --
WITH.
WILL -- WILL
HOLD A ROLE OPEN --
AND HOLD BACK ON OUR ADJOURNMENT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE TODAY BUT YOU DON'T NEED TO
STICK AROUND APPRECIATE IT.
SORRY ABOUT THAT.
THANK YOU.
FOR EITHER ONE WILL
RAISE.
ITEM TWO WILL REOPEN THE WRONG.
CURRENT VOTE FOUR ZERO CHAIR
VOTING I REVERSE
--
A WE ARE GOING TO ADJOURN THE
MEETING AT THIS TIME THANK YOU